this is jaco podcast number 82 with echo
Charles than me jaakor willing
good evening echo good evening I was
walking down the street and I was pretty
sure I would die and I did not mind in
fact a large part of me looked forward
to it
to that release to go to heaven to meet
Christ for it all to be over I courted
death like a sailor courts a twirling
Spanish barmaid I was not afraid
even as we trot across broken streets
with asphalt and makeshift concrete
piled like sloppy cake icing hiding the
surprises below large IEDs and screams
and blood and burning flesh and burning
vehicle tires all superficially hidden
all obviously present all a joke death
had been at the forefront of my mind and
part of my decision to become a soldier
at all and that's what I considered
myself a soldier a grunt an infantryman
a ground pounder a soldier what else is
there we all turned into soldiers on
patrol we competed with each other and
the men and other units and other
services to see who could patrol in the
most disciplined way we would see who we
could catch staring at his feet or not
watching his field of fire or not
scanning for threats or not keeping his
shooting hand on his gun and when the
shooting did start we would watch
to see who would panic and who would
cower these were seemingly fun games and
recesses breaking up the fear which was
so overpowering it put a deep ache in
our stomachs and in our bowels there was
chaos that brought me to this point wild
music as a young boy Slayer Metallica in
their prime venom Motorhead heavy
alcohol use by age 10 drug use by age 11
late-night Punk concerts and mosh pits
where I nearly lost my front tooth at
age 12 as it dug deeply into a Punk's
shaved head I was tall for my age and
people treated me like an adult they
tried to bring me into their filth
junkies perverts degenerates an evil
world burning so much so that war was a
dream come true it seemed as if now I
could fight back against the depravity
and evil that tried to engulf me and I
held that quiet hope that unspoken hope
that maybe I could die in war doing
something heroic like they trained us to
do
maybe this godforsaken and worthless
life could be over this
gauntlet and so the IE D Laden roads
attempting to scare me and us or a joke
and I did not care about it about the
setup about the punchline
I just wanted enemy contact and I wanted
to smell the blood of particles floating
through the afternoon air then the
screams of the dying that is what I
wanted it seemed so beautiful my mind
had romanticized it all but what we got
wasn't so romantic as it wasn't so
beautiful
most of the screams I heard with the
screams of my countrymen as they bled or
the screams of innocents who were in the
wrong place at the wrong time
I watched the funerals of men we shot
going right past us with children crying
the wives glaring as they dammed us with
ancient Babylonian curses that would try
to follow me back to my home in satanic
nightmares where I could not escape them
all those things made death so true and
so beautiful and so acceptable
[Music]
now those words were written by someone
that I served with in Ramadi in 2006 and
he sent them to me the other day after
we talked and I asked him to write down
what he thought about he was walking
down the street in Ramadi and obviously
what he wrote about it revealed so much
of the the incredible spectrum of
emotions and thoughts that run through
our heads and and obviously war
magnifies those but these are thoughts
of a human being and these are the kind
of thoughts that people have not just in
war but in life the struggles and as I
was sitting thinking about you know that
word and that the fact that struggle it
absolutely shapes us and I was talking
about this when I was with Jill Logan
and Chris Cornell from Soundgarden had
just killed himself and we were talking
about the struggles and Jill was saying
that destroy you know give you you've
got a kind of like struggle and you need
struggle people need struggle and some
of the feedback that I saw on social
media was you know there's a difference
between struggle and challenge and that
a challenge is good but struggle is bad
and you know I don't know I'm not
wishing struggles upon anyone I'm no
guru
but I do know that struggle and strife
shapes us it shapes us there's no doubt
and as I was thinking about this I
started thinking about a bunch of
different books that I've read in the
past and one of them is a book called
and we go on and it was written by a guy
named will our Berg who's from Nova
Scotia Canada and he was a soldier in
the Canadian Army in World War one and
he'd enlisted in the army to replace his
brother so his brother had been killed
in battle and he said okay I need to I
need to enlist now and at first he
couldn't let's get he had bad teeth and
then as more and more guys got killed
they loosened the standards and they
allowed him in even with his bad teeth
and the book is very different and we're
not going to go through the whole book
today but what makes the book different
is he talks about like the supernatural
and he wrote another book as a matter of
fact which is called ghosts have warm
hands and so this kind of supernatural
world or something he spends some pretty
decent amount of time on and in the
beginning of the book one of the things
that he says is the trench at zero hour
was a crucible that dissolved all
insincerity and the superficial and you
can clearly imagine that these guys
getting ready to go over the top I mean
what else matters at that point
everything that's not true is everything
that is not sincere just means nothing
at that point and I'm going to go to the
book here for for a minute
and here's one of the things he said
about sort of again I'm I've just
started thinking about the psychological
side of what people are going through so
here we go to the book this story is an
effort to reveal a side of war that has
not been given much attention
the psychic effect it had on its
participants there existed before all
battles and even in the calms of the
trench routine a condition before which
all natural explanations failed and no
supernatural explanations were
established every human emotion ran its
full gamut in that land of topsy-turvy
and prolonged intensity of feeling
wrought feeling wrought strange
psychological changes which warped the
soul itself never on earth was there a
place where a man's support often his
sole support was his faith in some
mighty power all intervening thoughts
were swept aside unconsciously there
were born faiths that men carried
through critical moments and tortured
Minds grasp fantasies that served in
place of more solid creeds
[Music]
I think it's interesting that he says
worked the soul and and I don't actually
think and again I'm no literary expert
but I don't think he means that with the
the negative connotation of warped being
negative and bad but I think he means
like a departure from the normal a
departure from the straight-line moving
away from the natural direction and so
it leaves it leaves men changed and like
I said not going to cover this this
whole book will probably do it at some
point in the future but I think when he
gets to the end of the book and he makes
some statements that are pretty powerful
and of course this is now after he's
gone through the war and he's on a ship
sailing back to Canada then I'm gonna
read this section here we go back to the
book darkness the rush of the ship I
felt my way again into a stifling dugout
into an atmosphere rancid with stale
sweat and breathing earth mold and the
hot grease of candles I saw faces cheeks
resting on tunics mud streaked unshaven
dirty faces with some with teeth
clenched and sudden hate some livid with
pulse stopping fear us on then turning
on the wire bunks quivering as if some
red-hot drill I heard them gasp and sob
and cry out in agony and mutter as they
tossed again then a machineguns note
louder higher sharper crack crack crack
as it sweeps over you in a shell hole
where you hug the earth the growl of
guttural voices heavy steps in an unseen
trench just the other side of the black
mass of tangled barbed barricade
which you power the long-drawn wine of a
shell it's hard gripping explosion the
terrible oppressive silence that follows
then the first low wail of the man who
is down with a gaping blood spurting
wound I moved about ship myself sniffed
the salt air and tried to rid myself of
my dreams and as I stood there there
came a sudden chill I grew cold as if I
had entered a clammy cavern I could not
understand but went and got my great
coat a dim figure passed me as I
returned to the deck and the voice said
we're getting nearer home I can feel the
change ah I knew we had left the warm
current and were into the icy waters
nearer home we had left behind the
comradeship of long hours on the trench
post and patrols long days under blazing
Suns and cruel marches on cobbled roads
the Brotherhood of the line and we were
entering a cold sea facing the dark the
unknown we could not escape dark figures
came and stood beside me I had not
thought that anyone save myself would
come on deck and here they were ten a
dozen still more all hunched in great
coats silent staring I looked at my
watch there was three o'clock in the
morning these men could not sleep they
were come to see the first lights of
Halifax I move quietly among them
scanning each blurred face it was as I
thought
they were all old-timers the men of the
trenches we went on and on and on and no
one spoke though we touched shoulders I
tried to think of a comparison ah
[Music]
we were like prisoners I had seen them
standing like that without speaking
staring thinking prisoners we were
prisoners prisoners who could never
escape I had been trying to imagine how
I would express my feelings when I got
home and now I knew I never could none
of us could we could no more make
ourselves articulate than could those
who would not return we were in a world
apart prisoners in Chains that would
never loosen till death freed us and I
knew those at home would never
understand they would be impatient
wondering why we were so dumb unable to
put our experiences into words and there
would be many of the boys who would be
surly taciturn moody resenting good
intentions perhaps taking too hard
liquor and aimless drifting we of the
Brotherhood could understand the soldier
but never explained him all of us would
remain a separate definite people as if
branded by some monstrous despotism
but I warmed as I fought of all that the
Brotherhood had meant the sharing of
blankets and bread and hardships the
binding of each other's wounds the talks
we had had of intimate things of the dug
and simple faith that men had showed
flashes of their inner selves that
strengthened one's own soul perhaps when
my bitterness passed when I had got back
to normal self to loved ones tried hard
by years of waiting I would find that
despite that horror which I could never
forget
I had equalizing treasure in memories I
could use like Jacob's Ladder to get
high enough to see that even war itself
could never be the whole of life the
water stirred I tingled my throat
tightened waves of emotion seized me
held me I grew hot and cold at queer
sensations every man had tensed praying
forward yet no one spoke it was the
moment for which we had lived which we
had dreamed visioned pictured a thousand
times it held us now so enthralled so
full of feelings that we could not find
utterance a million thrills ran through
me
far ahead st. but growing brighter
we had glimpsed the first lights of home
and that line when he says perhaps when
my bitterness has passed and I could use
my memories and he said he could use his
memories like jacob's ladder to get high
enough to see that even a war itself
could never be the whole of life and
those of his struggles he's talking
about those are the hardships and this
this change in his mindset to not let
those drag him down but but to use those
to climb up and I think I think we you
we lose track of that sometimes and all
we see is the trench when we get stuck
in the trench and I think it's
interesting that these men literally and
metaphorically speaking these men were
in trenches but they were able to rise
out of these trenches these trenches of
unimaginable suffering and I I think to
myself if they are able to rise out of
those hellish trenches then that means
we can too
we came to and again this this thing
that my this thing that my buddy sent me
they just got me thinking about that
psychological turmoil of war and that
sent me into thoughts of another book
again another book that I read awhile
back I mean remember when I read it but
I just sort of thinking about it and
this one was about Vietnam and it's a
classic it's it's called a rumor of war
and again we will absolutely cover this
book on the podcast in detail at some
point but I'm kind of just was on this
literary tour mode and the psyche I
think it's just a good view of the
psyche that people have in war which
again reflects life and there's a
section in this book where Phil Caputo
is assigned to a rear echelon unit he's
in the rear and you know he's a
lieutenant the Marine Corps he's in the
rear and I think he's in a regimental
command post or something but he's not
fighting and here's what he thinks of
that going to the book in the middle of
November at my own request I was
transferred to a line company in 1st
battalion my convictions about the war
had eroded almost to nothing I had no
illusions but I had volunteered for a
line company anyway there were a number
of reasons of which the paramount was
boredom there was nothing for me to do
but count casualties I felt useless and
a little guilty about living in relative
safety while other men risked their
lives I cannot deny that the front still
held fascination for me
the rights are wrongs of the war aside
there was a magnetism about combat you
seem to live more intensely under fire
every sense was sharper the mind worked
clearer and faster perhaps it was the
tension of opposites that made it so an
attraction balanced by revulsion hope
that Ward with dread you found yourself
on a precarious emotional edge
experienced experiencing a heaviness
that no drink or drug could match the
fear of madness was another motive the
hallucination I had had and that that
day and the mess of seeing more on
Harrison prefigured and death had become
a constant waking nightmare I'd begun to
see almost everyone as they would look
in death including myself shaving in the
mirror in the morning I could see myself
dead then there were moments when I not
only saw my own corpse but other people
looking at it I saw life going on
without me the sensation of not being
anymore came over me at night just
before falling asleep sometimes it made
me laugh inside I could not take myself
seriously when I could already see my
own death nor seeing their deaths as
well could I take others seriously we
were all the victims of a great
practical joke played on us by God or
nature maybe that was why corpses always
grinned they saw the joke at the last
moment sometimes it made me laugh but
most of the time it was not at all
humorous and I was sure that another few
months of identifying bodies would land
me in a psychiatric ward on staff there
was too much time too
brood over those corpses there would be
very little time to think in a line
company that is the secret to emotional
survival in war not thinking finally
there was hatred a hatred buried so deep
that I could not then admit its
existence
I can now though it is still painful I
burned with a hatred for the Vietcong
and with an emotion that dwells in most
of us one closer to the surface than we
care to admit a desire for retribution I
did not hate the enemy for their
politics but for murdering Simpson for
executing that boy whose body had been
found in the river for blasting the life
out of wall levy revenge was one of the
reasons I volunteered for a line company
I wanted a chance to kill somebody and
you can see even in that the you know
comparing that with the first piece of
things being a joke and how you just
hard you just get to this point where
things just become a joke how can you
take anything seriously when you don't
even know what's going to happen and if
you're going to live how much meaning
does life have if you're not going to
live it
he gets back out to a line company and
now he's on patrol talking about not
only what that's like externally but
what it's like mentally psychologically
going back to the book I tightened the
shoulder straps of my pack heavily
loaded with signal flares smoke grenades
dry socks a poncho and three days
rations and entrenching tool and machete
were lashed to its side in my pockets I
carried a map compass hand grenades more
flares
haleh's own tablets malaria pills and a
spare magazine for my carbine a pistol
two clips of ammunition knife first-aid
kit and two full canteens hung from my
belt my steel helmet and flak jacket
added 20 pounds to the load the gear
probably weighed over 40 pounds
altogether but I felt a wonderful
soaring lightness in my limbs I felt
good all over better than I had felt in
months even Neil who is not inclined to
hand out compliments had praised my
gung-ho enthusiasm before the platoon
left Basecamp a sudden and mysterious
recovery from the virus of fear had
caused the change in mood I don't know
why I only knew I had ceased to be
afraid of dying there was not a feeling
of invincibility indifference rather I
had ceased to fear death because I had
ceased to care about it certainly I had
no illusions that my death if it came
would be a sacrifice they would merely
be a death and not a good one either a
good death involved a certain amount of
choice ritual and style there were no
good deaths in the war
but the manner of dying no longer
mattered I didn't care how death came so
long as it came quickly and painlessly I
would die as casually as a beetle is
crushed under a boot heel and perhaps it
was this recognition of my insect-like
pettiness that had made me stop caring I
was a beetle we were all beetles
scratching for survival in the
wilderness those who had lost the
struggle had not changed anything by
dying the deaths of levi simpson
sullivan and the others had not made any
difference thousands of people died each
week in the war and the sum of all their
deaths did not make any difference the
war went on without them and as it went
on without them so would it go on
without me my death would not alter a
thing walking down the trail i could not
remember having self an emotion more
sublime or liberating then that
indifference toward my own death
[Music]
again a common thought pattern is this
this feeling of hey I'm in hell and one
thing like trying to set me free is
death and once I overcome that that that
just allows me to go and do what I'm
supposed to do and I'm just going to
fast forward once again kind of like
with the will bird going to the end
where where Caputo kind of wraps up his
what he's gonna bring home from the war
and at this point he's you know he's
obviously survived the enemy he survived
actually at this point he survived a
court-martial because he'd gotten in
some trouble there was some bad things
that happened while he was in charge
there was you know cases against him and
he kind of got out of that situation and
now he is heading home going back to the
book we stood waiting in the Sun at the
edge of the runway there were about a
hundred and fifty of us and we watched
as a replacement draft filed off the big
transport plane they fell into formation
and tried to ignore the dusty tanned
ragged looking man who jeered them the
replacements looked strangely young far
younger than we and awkward and
bewildered by this scorched land to
which and indifferent government had
sent them I did not join in the mockery
I felt sorry for those children knowing
that they would all grow old in this
land of endless dying I pitied them
knowing that out of every ten one would
die two more would be maimed for life
another two would be less seriously
wounded and sent out to fight again and
all the rest would be wounded in other
more hidden ways
the replacements were marched off toward
the convoy that awaited to carry them to
their assigned units and their assigned
fates none of them looked at us they
marched away shouldering our SI bags we
climbed up the ramp into the plane the
plane we had all dreamed about the grand
mythological freedom bird a joyous shout
went up as the transport lurched off the
runway and climbed into the placid sky
below lay the rice paddies and the green
folded hills where we had all lost our
friends and our youth the plane banked
and headed out over the China Sea
towards Okinawa toward freedom from
deaths embrace none of us was a hero we
would not return to cheering crowds
parades and the pealing of great
cathedral bells we had done nothing more
than endure we had survived and that was
our only victory
[Music]
and I think that is important for us to
remember that in some cases some of the
things that we go through some of the
things some of the challenges and
tribulations and trials that people get
put through sometimes survival is
victory and all you can do is survive
and make it through a situation that
you're in and I think sometimes when
people survive something or horrible
instead of being happy or elated that
they made it through instead they focus
on the fact that they got put through it
[Music]
and again I don't I'm no professional at
all and there was you know there was
there was you know even when I was on
Joe Rogan's podcasting and we were
talking about Chris Cornell committing
suicide you know someone said you know
cuz we kind of devolved into a
conversation of hey you know get outside
and Tim Ferriss when Tim Ferriss was on
this podcast you know he was saying you
know get move and get physical and so
you know Joe and I were just kind of
talking about that and and and someone
came on and said you know you don't know
what you're talking about it's it's it's
you're lucky to survive something like
this it's horrible and and you know I
kind of said man I I know I'm not saying
that and and literally ivory listened to
Joe and I talking in both of us of what
we were saying was over and over again I
don't understand this I don't comprehend
it you know so I don't think that was
the intention we're saying oh all you
have to do is go get it out of
kettlebell and you'll be good to go
that's not the intention at all and
that's not what either one of us not
only was it were not what we were trying
to say we didn't actually say that
we were saying hey I don't understand it
I haven't been in that position before
that's why we brought that's why I
brought Tim on here because Tim had
lived through that and and knew how bad
it was and planned to kill himself and
so that to me is someone that can give
their opinion Joe and I were literally
saying I don't comprehend but I think
when you get a guy
like the author of this book a rumor for
who's who's talking about their their
victory or his victory and the people on
the play their victory in Vietnam was
survival was just getting through it I
know that's nothing you're gonna be
joyous about but I think at least
recognizing okay I made it through now
let me move on yeah is important now
again I I went on this kind of literary
tour that I was launched into after
reading what what my buddy wrote because
it reminded me of so many other things
that I've heard and so many other things
that I've read and so another great you
know viewpoint comes from Eugene sledge
and he wrote the book with the old breed
which is a classic and we covered it
podcast number 10 if you want to stop
now go back and listen to podcast 10
with Eugene sled with Eugene sledge with
the old breed it's just incredible
account of what he went through in World
War 2 in the in the Pacific Theater with
the Marine Corps but he wrote another
book after that and the next book that
he wrote was called China marine and it
talks about what they did when the war
ended you know at the time he spent sort
of pacifying and in-country spent some
time in China and then it talks about
what it was like when he got back to
America back to Mobile Alabama and it's
definitely impactful definitely
impactful so here's what he came to came
home to and I'm gonna pick up where his
dad he's talking to his dad his dad was
a physician during World War one and
that's one of the reasons his dad was if
you remember Eugene sledge couldn't get
in the Marine Corps at first because he
had I think he had a heart murmur or
something like that
I didn't let him in and his dad was kind
of okay with that then the reason he was
okay with that was because he had seen
what the boys from World War one had
come home like not only physically but
also psychologically guys had two guys
had the shell shock which is horrible
when you see and again I've said this
before go on YouTube and look at videos
of World War one shell shock it's it's
horrifying to look at and that's what
Eugene sledge his father had seen and so
when his son couldn't go in the Marine
Corps he was kind of like limp okay you
know you can serve in other ways and
Eugene sledge wanted to serve and so
Eugene sledge got he actually got a
waiver and the and I guess the heart
murmur had faded enough or they didn't
notice it until we got the Marine Corps
when he comes back his dad he that is
talking to him and I think it's a good
place to pick up his dad called him
fritz that was that was Eugene sledge
his nickname at home so here we go
Eugene sledge his dad talking to him
fritz
he said I know you've been through an
awful experience I know that nobody had
it worse than the first Marine Division
except maybe those on Bataan and those
others who were imprisoned I'm
tremendously proud of both you and
Edward you did your duty under
terrifying conditions but you survived
in one piece granted with some terrible
memories you'll have to learn to live
with but take my advice first never
become embittered because many other men
had safe comfortable war assignments all
too often obtained through political
influence that's the way of cowards in
this world to never feel sorry for
yourself because of what you endured on
the contrary feel fiercely proud that
you served with the finest and fought
against the fiercest enemy and lived to
tell the tale
three if you ever drink alcohol do it in
moderation alcohol can be a wonderful
escape from bad memories but it is
addictive
we'll make you act the fool and
ultimately ruin you to the last remark I
replied I know father I've seen that
happen to good buddies recalling some of
the worst cases in China he replied yes
and I've treated some of the nicest
people who were ruined by the stuff but
I can't cure them they must have
willpower
so really straightforward warning about
alcohol check about not feeling bitter
towards people that didn't maybe do or
go through what he went through and be
proud of what you did now this is again
just another piece that that they
actually in in the HBO miniseries the
Pacific they they kind of portray this
part of Eugene sledge coming home but
it's worth reading his account of it
back to the book as my life settled down
somewhat I began to think of my future
rather hastily I decided to go to Auburn
then called Alabama Polytechnic
Institute and major in business I'll
never forget my first day at Auburn I
was in the registrar's office in Sanford
Hall the big room was crowded with long
lines of entering students standing in
front of tables behind which clerks were
noticing or noting each student's
college credits from service schools
determining which might transfer to
Auburn there was a loud hubbub of voices
with about a hundred people in the room
some men mostly Air Corps veterans had
been to various technical schools and
Auburn gave them two years credit all
veterans were excused from ROTC and
physical education when I stepped up to
the table at the head of the line pretty
brunette about my age probably a
student's wife asked pleasantly what
schools I had had attended in the Marine
Corps I recited all the weapons and
tactics schools we had in training she
became more and more disconcerted as she
looked in vain
on her checklist for anything remotely
resembling what I was saying finally in
desperation she slammed her pencil on
the table and said in a loud exasperated
voice did the Marine Corps teach you
anything a gasp ran through the crowd
and you could have heard a pin drop I
didn't lose my temper but I realized
that like most civilians warned this
lady meant John Wayne or the sweet
musical South Pacific slowly placing my
hands on the table
aware that aah all eyes were upon us I
said in a loud calm voice lady there was
a killing war the Marine Corps taught me
how to kill Japs and try to survive now
if that don't fit into any academic
course I'm sorry but some of us had to
do the killing and most of my buddies
got killed or wounded she was speechless
there were many red faces among the
obvious non-combatants present I doubt
if there were half a dozen in terms of
men or tankers present she recovered her
composure looked me in the eye and said
I'm so sorry I lie upon eyes I didn't
understand I told her she was very kind
and I did not mean to upset her you
didn't she said you made me think so I
got credit for ROTC and PE and the room
returned to normal the young lady wished
me a long and happy life I thanked her
and left I felt like some sort of an
alien and I realized that this sort of
thing would confront me the rest of my
days the war had been so momentous to me
I couldn't imagine anyone not sharing
that view or or appreciating the hell I
had suffered in fact I was totally
unprepared for how rapidly most
Americans who did not experience combat
would forget about the war the evils we
say
and how incredibly tough it had been for
us to defeat the Japanese and the Nazis
I didn't realize how swiftly most
Americans would once again take their
freedom for granted
[Music]
clearly that applies to veterans and
people that have been overseas fighting
and you come back and it's like no one
even knows that you were gone it's like
another thing you need you get that
passage of time when you go away for two
or three months and you go back to where
you're from and it seems like oh how
long you been gone for all three months
oh it seems people think you were gone
for a couple days or a couple weeks yeah
yeah it happens at the gym like I'll go
into the gym and and then someone where
you been you know I think I haven't seen
him in a week he says oh I tore my ACL
I've been gone for eight months you know
it's one of those moments and that
happens with war two guys go away they
come back every you know time just went
by and that can be frustrating because
in those eight months or six months or
14 months that someone's deployed
overseas fighting for their lives they
come home and and that other person
didn't even notice they were gone yeah I
mean I feel bad when somebody had an ACL
tear and I didn't know it you know I
feel kind of bad yeah and I haven't seen
you for eight months you know if you
feel like I feel bad about it and I'm
sure that person saying you know jock
with geese we used to train all the time
and you didn't even realize that I was
gone you thought I was gone for a week
right meaning kind of yeah exactly
well imagine how that feels to a veteran
that's coming back from war and that is
this isn't this isn't like some odd case
this is the norm that's actually the
norm yeah I mean it's different for the
direct family that's waiting for the
individuals come home then those
six-month deployment or 14 months
deployments seem like an eternity yeah
but for that casual person or that
acquaintance that you don't know that
well they're thinking oh oh did you
where you been
yeah oh yeah I was overseas fighting
yeah
and he's got the way he kind of wraps up
this book in his epilogue and again you
know this is another book that we'll
probably explore at some point in detail
but going to the way that the topics
that he brings up as it closes out
reflections on how the war impacted him
psychologically here we go back to the
book looking back over the momentous
events of fifty years ago when I was a
marine evokes strong emotions the years
immediately after the war were the
hardest as Paul Fussell remarked the
combat veteran not only has to survive
his experience he has to learn to live
with it the rest of his life he was so
right for the first twenty odd years
after my return nightmares occurred
frequently waking me either crying or
yelling always sweating and with a
pounding heart some nights I delayed
going to bed dreading the inevitable
nightmares old comrades wrote me that
similar troubles drove many of them to
drink and to the ensuing misery of
alcoholism which they beat with sheer
self-discipline eventually the war left
me with a deep appreciation for the
simple things in life
putting on a clean pair of dry socks is
one of the greatest luxuries I know a
shave
a warm shower and sleeping in a sheeted
bed are two when it is raining
especially on an autumn day I look out
the window at the falling drops and my
thoughts sometimes drift back to those
awful days on Okinawa snafu and die
bailing out a muddy foxhole with an old
helmet shivering in a torrential cold
grave and both of us
cringing as each Japanese shell came
screaming into the corpse rune area to
explode with a deafening crash and
quickly bring my mind the focus of my
mind back to the present and thank God
is not to suffer hardship and misery
again and oh what a blessing to be
relieved of constant terror my love of
the outdoors were strangely affected by
the war the way I looked at my
surroundings was altered my view of the
outdoors had taken a more analytical
perspective of its features as military
terrain likely areas for the placement
of various foxholes the company 60
millimeter mortars to cover deflates
the light machine guns so as to achieve
cross fires along the company front
fields of fire and possible avenues of
enemy attack or ambush this change in
outlook was intense in the early years
home but I cleared my mind of it by
concentrating on plant and animal
species present or probable but the old
combat view of things still creeps in
sometimes after more than 50 years and
that's something that definitely stood
every guy I know that's been overseas
every guy everything we look at we see
that some kind of military terrain in a
city for me especially it's in the city
because I did most of my combat with
urban combat and that's so I'm looking
at all the time not only on the highway
on the buildings when you're sitting
around when you're sitting in a hotel
room looking out the street everything
that you look at you look at from a
combat perspective now hee hee hee was a
outdoorsman and he goes back he gets
back from the war and he's going hunting
and this is the first time that he's
gone deer hunting after the war and he's
out hunting with a group of people but
he gets dropped off in one spot by
himself to have a boat by River they
take a boat
pop them off alone and here we go back
to the book
- beautiful doze appeared walking
briskly through the water as they exited
the woods and stopped at the far edge of
the pond about thirty yards away they
kept looking toward the area of the
drive and moving their ears to capture
every sound possible more loud sloshing
of water and two dough's and a large
buck came up to the first doze and
stopped they finally looked in my
direction I remain still and since the
wind was blowing toward me the deer
could not pick up my scent
they stood motion motionless staring at
me and standing up in the clump of cane
they seemed more concerned with the
baying of the hounds than with me though
because of the way I held my rifle I
could see my wristwatch so I timed the
action or inaction of the deer one of
the dough's picked up an acorn at the
edge of the pond and ate it the buck was
large and had a fine set of antlers the
eight points gleaming in the light
slowly I raised my rifle and sighted in
on his chest no he was too fine a
creature to kill I had murdered one of
his kind that morning so I did not need
to venison slowly I lowered my rifle the
buck remained motionless motionless his
instincts probably told him no shape
such as he saw in the cane was natural
deer like most mammals have very poor
sight except for detecting motion and
are primarily colorblind for fifteen
minutes we stared at each other a shot
in the air would send them springing
away into the woods but a shot would
frighten them which I had no desire to
do the deer seemed more curious than
afraid they kept sniffing the air which
apparently borne no scent of danger
I had on waterproof boots but was
beginning to get cold
finally I needed to move a little I knew
that as soon as I did they would bolt so
I whistled softly
every big ear turned quickly in my
direction i whistled softly again all
the deer slowly lowered their ears
turned went sloshing on the higher
ground and ambled into the woods looking
back at me once or twice the whole
episode is one of my most cherished
memories when Jim picked me up in the
boat he asked if I had seen a deer I
said no not wanting to tell him I had
seen five when we return to camp several
people asked me what I had seen and I
reported a few squirrels and some wood
ducks if I told those eager hunters what
had really happened they would have
elected to throw me in the river gust
didn't allow any drinking during hunting
hours so after the guns were all
unloaded in putting their cases the
bottled spirits were brought forth and
the partiers all had a ball each of the
weary hounds went to the fenced yard
jumped up on the raised platforms and
went into the barrel for a nap the
platform was raised as protection
against high water as well as alligators
which have a special appetite for dog
flesh weary crossed the river after a
while and scattered to our homes so
ended my last deer hunt but the memory
of that beautiful buck and his harem
down the river I've wondered how long he
survived I am NOT anti hunting as long
as it is managed by wildlife experts
most game animals out produce their food
supply and since civilization has
destroyed most of the natural predators
starvation results unless populations
are controlled by game management
overseeing proper hunting practices but
the terrified eyes of that spike buck I
shot or something
I'd like to forget I have felt the same
terror when being shot at
so hunting is not for me World War two
gave me a convenient measuring stick for
duty courage terror friendship patience
horror endurance compassion discomfort
grief and pain that has remained with me
daily the English poet Robert Graves
said World War one affected him in much
the same way anyone who has not suffered
the prolonged fear and limitless fatigue
that was combat that was the combat
infantryman's lot might find this
difficult to comprehend over fifty years
later I look back on the war as though
it were some giant killing machine into
which we were thrown to endure fear to
the brink of insanity some fell over the
brink and physical fatigue to near
collapse those who survived unhurt will
never forget and cannot forget the many
friends lost in their prime and the many
articles of civilization they ruthlessly
destroyed as I look back some facts are
quite clear
Japan's sneaked bombing of Pearl Harbor
destroyed many American lives ships and
planes we had no choice but to destroy
Imperial Japan the a-bomb ended that war
it saved millions of American lives by
preventing a murderous invasion of Japan
and the probable destruction of a
suicidal Japanese population the
Japanese soldier was a bloodthirsty foe
imbued with the code of Bushido
if we had not defeated an army that
thought it was unbeatable who knows how
many American cities might have shared
the horrid Rape of Nanking in looking
back I'm still amazed I escaped the
killing machine why I never fell killed
or wounded in that storm of Steel thrown
at us countless times still astonishes
me I'm proud of the number of the enemy
I fired on and hit with my mortar rifle
or tommy gun and regret the ones I
missed
there is no mellowing for me that would
be to forgive all the atrocities the
Japanese committed against millions of
Asians and thousands of Americans to
mellow is to forget each man who
survived I am certain was plucked from
the mire of death by the Almighty and in
this I feel humble and grateful Socrates
said know thyself
I do the war taught me
[Music]
the war taught me is how he closes out
that book and the war taught me as well
and the war still teaches me and that's
why I read about war and why I talk
about war and that's why so much of this
podcast is about war because war can
teach us but it's not only war that
teaches us life life teaches us but
that's that's only if we are humble and
open-minded enough and a tentative
enough to watch then listen and learn
from it not only from our own paths and
the things we go through but from what
we see other people do it's a teacher
life is a teacher and yet and you see
this all the time there are people that
do not learn from life and they make the
same mistakes over and over and over
again just completely unaware of the
lessons that are they are smacking them
in the face smacking them in the face I
think that's where you have to flip the
switch in your brain that that hardship
that you're facing that trial that
tribulation embedded in that misery
is a lesson
[Music]
the teacher and it's only a lesson if
you're willing to learn from it
the hand life is a hard teacher but do
your best to listen and to learn from it
and you know speaking of learning I last
Facebook live got some some good
questions mm-hm and I noticed a little
rough transition nah man
Bloodgood um you know it's just kind of
a going through all those different
different people's books and you can see
what war did to them and you can see the
similarities with all of them that human
beings put in really stressful
situations human beings put in life to
have similar outcomes right I mean
there's there's commonalities in it I
think the more we look for those
commonalities and the more individual
you me the more I look for these
commonalities and in different people's
experiences the better off I'm going to
be right the more I'm going to be able
to understand what's happening to the
world around me yeah or to the people
around me yeah that's the one thing that
I think it's really important as is
seeing you know when you start talking
about that the life lessons hit you in
the face it's always if you're the
person that's getting hit that's the
your even though you're the person that
stands to gain the most from from
understanding what's going on around you
you're also the person has the hardest
time recognizing it it's just like when
you're sitting outside of an MMA match
or an anime MMA fight and you as the
coach as the cornermen you can see
what's happening and the guy that's
getting punched in the face a lot of
times they don't see what's hitting them
and they don't think of it as a lesson
they don't they're not to take
anything positive away from it they're
getting punched in the face yes and it's
not until someone says hey the guy's
hitting you with the left hook you're
you know you're or you're dropping your
hands or whatever so the person can make
a correction they're not learning from
it they're getting hit and that's what
happens to a lot of us in life is we're
getting punched in the face punched in
the face punch in the face and we don't
recognize we can't step back we can't
detach from being in that situation
where we can actually assess what's
going on and say oh okay I see what's
going on here yeah I ask you what I see
what changes I got to make that's why
and then what happens is this is what
happens well what happens is you say oh
echo I see you're going through some
hard times so I go up to you say any
echo this is what you're doing this is
what you should change and what happens
big ego flare up for that go you know
I'm I don't know how I feel you know
what's going on you don't know what it's
like you don't know what it feels like
getting punched in the face bro I'm just
trying to help you you don't get it so
what we do are in our instinct is to put
up defenses even when somebody's trying
to help us out right so that means you
got to get good at trying to help people
out too because we already know that
everyone gets defensive and that
everyone's ego flares up and that when
you talk to your friend that's either a
vet coming home and he's facing problems
or someone that's having a hard time at
work or someone that's having a hard
time relationship or someone that's
having a hard time with whatever
addictions gotten ahold of them all
those things you got to learn how to how
to talk to those people in a way that
you're not being offensive to them which
is hard to do because we all take
offense whenever somebody tells us that
we're doing something wrong we're all
offended by it we're all offended by it
even the most positive helpful person
your own your mom right your mom comes
to tell you something you get offended
all right your your best friend comes
and says hey you know you you're doing
this you're going down the wrong path
here you don't know nothing about my
path you know so having that detachment
so you can see yourself and then having
an open mind when somebody tries to help
you and then when you are trying to help
someone trying to do it in a way that
you don't attack their ego those are
some good things to think about as
you're going through life trying to take
lessons away from it and so crazy
applied again applies to everything that
you know it's like when would you ever
hear people say if I knew then what I
know now that of course right under my
life look at the jacked-up thing is
there's all kinds of people that know
now that tried to tell you then yeah
there's so much there's so many places
to get this information you're saying if
I knew then what I knew now well then
guess what all kinds of people were
trying to help you yeah we're trying to
help me we're trying to tell me what to
do I wasn't listening at him yeah my
egos too big I know what I'm doing I'm
the smartest person in the world you
don't understand the situation it's
going to be different for me my life is
special my life is different yeah all
those things all those things that we
say so just life we just had an open
mind to listen to what people were
trying to tell us yeah or or at a
minimum have an open mind to listen to
what life was trying to tell us hard
it's funny because it's so true like how
you when you're when you say if I knew
then what I know now and you say it
won't back then there was people but
yelling at you yeah screaming
metaphorically yes yeah right there
giving you that knowledge so you could
have known then what you know now kind
of theta then you got to go one step
deeper and go dang well I should have
known then to listen to you guys you
know I know to listen you guys now kind
of thing and it's like it's almost like
this borderline Impossibles in there it
is a hard scenario there's some things
in life and this is so unfortunate that
you have to learn only from life it was
all these I know that stupid things that
people go through and you just you just
you watching them go through it yeah and
and again I talk about this story where
you you you get you get someone that's
going down a downward spiral you pick
the downward spiral that they're on
whether it's the relationship that
they're in is a disaster whether they're
getting addicted to whatever you want to
get addicted to yeah you know whether
that
work whether that's alcohol whether
that's drugs whether that's gambling
whatever thing you want to be addicted
to you pick the downward spiral that you
want to jump on the person that's on
that downward spiral if they don't see
it in everybody that's outside of the
spiral can absolutely identify it and
tell them then they don't wanna get off
I mean I know hey addictions are
horrible right and that's why they're
called addictions and that's why people
ride that downward spiral until it
destroys them like Eugene sledge as dad
talked about today it'll ruin you yeah
the only way out is willpower the only
way out and then Eugene says you got to
defeat it with pure self-discipline yeah
yeah you can you can have fun little
games with your mind and win it's their
little like chess matches which with
your mind with alcohol I know that from
experience and I win it when we first
started doing the podcast I didn't
realize that you drink as much as you
drink at that time yeah I was like
because we were recording yeah and you
hear you poured one out of it what are
you doing bro I'm like in here to
breathe you know get after it and you're
gonna have a drink during this yeah well
in my slight defense that one drink
wouldn't really affect ya anything and I
know this because other people tell me
this and I feel this where even if I'll
get hammered this is back then you
couldn't really tell that people would
be like oh you don't even seem at all me
know on the inside I'm like but yeah
because and here's another thing and
this can apply to a lot of people I
think not everybody but maybe some
people where you know how I was a kind
where I would only drink at home when I
did work here's the thing though I work
bizarre things yeah when I know I took a
textbook definition of an alcoholic
drinking at home alone while you're
working yeah I'm sure it's one of the
simple symptoms but straight up but on
potential when I went to like the bar or
so like hang out I didn't really go to
the clam you know after I stopped
working a club I aren't doing but you
know that go hang out and stuff I turned
way less I wouldn't even really want to
drink that much
but at home working that's when I drink
but like I said I work every single
night and for a long time too so it was
like every night for like using years
and years but the only problems that it
would kind of create were these kind of
covert problems like the next day I
wasn't is driven to do much I'd work out
a go train I do all the stuff that you
know I've been doing for whatever years
but you know like how you learn
something new to bring you know X Y Z
element of your life to the next level
kind of thing it would really get in the
way of that so you kind of stay in that
level like three yeah but here's the
same you know in certain ways I was
learning a lot because you learn a lot
when I work and stuff when I do you know
all these programs and do video stuff
you learn a lot while you do it
so man I was I was learning and getting
better at my stuff so in a way the
problems like I said weren't real
obvious and then after a while like
after time goes you know what it was
what really brought the problems to
light was something hang with you
because you'd be like okay we're here
now we're going here to this week we're
on like a whole different thing and I'm
like man I can hardly keep up with Jaco
so at night I'd be like oh yeah I'm
keeping up with jockle but the next day
I'm thinking when you're doing stuff
early in the morning you do doing stuff
during the day you're letting me know
okay now we got this and I'm like dang I
didn't say security been recovering all
day because I don't feel that good I did
a workout because we used to record the
podcast at night yeah late at night yeah
and so we'd get down at 1 o'clock in the
morning yeah and yeah I'd have to get
after in the morning and you'd not have
to yeah exactly right so it's weird ID
when you do that routine you get this
weird second I think your body just gets
ready to do work in the stuff you know
you do something over and over your body
just kind of just accommodates the
schedule so I was like at night I do
fine but during the day and what I want
to do nothing meanwhile you're you know
doing all this stuff and I'm like then
not to mention all the things that we
talked about like oh I got tricked by my
brain mm-mean what at the expense of my
whole life aside from those you know for
the other thing that sucks for you is
that because you were kind of because
the problems were covert there wasn't
any I'm assuming that there wasn't any
external people trying to help you and
be like hey echo your
you shouldn't drink at night because
you're still maintaining an acceptable
standard of humanity so and you you're
taking care of your wife you're taking
care of your young daughter and so
you're doing what you're responsible to
do your what your responsibilities are
we're being handled they're just being
handled at level three and level three
was okay maybe but I thought that was
where you were at
you know actually and this may sound
better but this is worse they were being
held at level essentially level ten
everything like I care everything I
cared about was being handled everything
like to the really high level like
hanging with the kids talking with so my
wife had good bit earlier than me so
then say late working working drinking I
can still wake up I'd be messed you know
not not that like happy to be awake but
I was that would never that would never
show dealing with other people and then
there'd be time to worth if I was just
too and really just I just felt tired
that's what it was I didn't feel
hungover you know this is actually
brings up a good point is that I think a
lot of times people spend wet because
they're because they're achieving a
minimum standard or maybe even a medium
standard yeah working
Molly or a solid standard in your case
from your perspective to me what I was
working yeah you're working you're
getting your job done
yeah making making part of your family
and doing workouts like hard work ups
during the day but everything else has
like come with us I get it I guess
there's always so basically if you're
not looking at yourself with a critical
eye you can get by with a lot as a
person as a human being you if you're
not looking if you're not looking at
yourself with a critical eye you are
going to get you you're not going to
reach your potential because you're not
going to push yourself as hard as you
possibly can which is you know the MMA
fighters but I was trained a lot of MMA
fighters I would tell them listen you
can train without a coach and you can
train too let's let's say you're super
disciplined you can get to like 84% this
is an interesting dichotomy you can get
to 84%
of your max output of you're pushing
yourself a coach is then going to take
you to the next level and he's going to
get you to 98 percent but this is what's
interesting the last 2% and goes back on
the individual so let's say I'm training
you for jiu-jitsu tournament if you just
trained yourself for the Judah
tournament you get to 80 82 percent of
your potential if I because that means
because you're you know you get to the
last round and you look at your girl you
know what I'm probably I might get hurt
this round so I take it off or I'm like
you know you're gonna make all those
excuses
you're not going to old hold the line
right now if I'm training you now okay
okay because you got to be here yep back
we're gonna do two more rounds hey
you're done with your rounds can do some
burpees you know I'm gonna I'm gonna
make you do that stuff so that's what a
coach does but then you take this last
that's going to get you to 98 percent
but the last two percent is back to you
because I can't make you do the burpees
as hard as you can I can make you do
them but I can't make you do them as
hard as you can I can't I can make you
do another round on the mat but I can't
make you do it
as hard as you can I can't make you try
moves the data that you don't feel like
trying yeah so it takes a little
teamwork in those situations now and
that's something I definitely saw with
with MMA fighters is yeah without a
coach they're not going to push
themselves hard yeah with a coach that
push themselves harder but if you're
going to be a champion you got to get
that last two percent yourself yeah and
what's crazy if you can you can kind of
make someone your coach even if they
don't know it you know how like um we're
I mean I think you'd kind of know that
you're kind of the coach you know as far
as good your coach should probably
anyone who interacts with you in your
regular basis they're going to cut it at
the very least look at you and know that
you wake up early and get a lot done for
for a reason by the way so they know
that so it's kind of like okay I can
follow suit you know I can take cues
from Jocko in this way and I can improve
it doesn't have to be in the exact
things that you're doing but just rough
the date
so I think if you actively do that where
I mean I'm speaking from a place of
supreme luxury by the way in regards to
this or you know I'm like you're talking
about it directly to me every single
week and I'm like yes sir and I go back
and try it you know try my best to apply
to to my stuff so of course but you can
do that even if you watch someone on I
don't know online or something or you
read it you know how people do like
blogs and stuff like that you know if
you're like a subscriber to a specific
blog and you really like you know to the
way they they do things or whatever you
can you can get that same effect in a
smaller way I think but you can have
that thinking back and definitely like
you just you got to be like conscious of
it though and how you say like you have
to have your own self like it's self
discipline for sure but um what did you
say you just said it's self awareness
look at yourself with a critical eye
yeah that you you got to do that in
here's the opposite of that in my
opinion and from what I've seen the
enemy of looking at yourself with a
critical eye is being good at justifying
stuff yeah especially you know I can how
they say smart people are dangerous in
that way be a really good at gosh
because yeah rationalizing something and
justifying something is exactly what it
is it is exactly what that says it's
justifying it yeah are you justified in
XYZ and if you are you are so if you can
justify something to yourself and you're
good at it
okay in your mind is literally okay is
not a good situation it's very dangerous
yes the very name is critical Eiffel got
a critical I think I mean I call
yourself out yeah if you want to reach
your maximum potential and move from
level 3 you know to at least level at
feet yeah man so what I was saying is
that got some pretty good little
rapid-fire questions you know I didn't
want to take a bunch of time on them but
I just want to at least address some of
the questions that came on the facebook
he live sure I've got a stack of
questions that have been coming in on
Facebook and Twitter and those two
primarily sure is where the big
questions come in to and I got a stack
of those that
we'll get around to in a QA at some
point and also a lot of questions that
get asked right now heard them before
so if you have a question if you haven't
listened to the podcast at this point
you might want to just go back and
listen to the other guests because the
question that you have about how many
hours of sleep at night and what time I
go to bed and you know those kind of
things they're there in the podcast and
you don't I'm not going to talk about
too much anymore you can have like um
your Luck's Jeopardy there would have
been something cool about stopping the
podcast at number 25 and said that's it
so you get and just because we addressed
a bunch of stuff and then just let it
marinate for a while like that would be
season one you know how they do that I'm
showing a good idea then we should have
done that we should done season one and
then paused mm-hm and let people really
have marinated that first season and
then season two comes in both see I like
that you would you wouldn't you wouldn't
never let that happen that's what I
think well it depends because it's
strategically it's a good idea
it's a strategically good idea yeah I
think it is because also you're going to
let that stuff marinate and then you're
going to get good feedback on a bulk of
work that people can then say hey this
was a good area of topics that you
discussed please we address and get the
following concerns right and so we could
attack those those concerns in such a
manner yeah I guess that's one way here
let me I think this is I'm speaking
selfishly here mm-hmm but I think this
is a big deal where even if you repeat
yourself even if you have answer the
same question literally the same
question over and over again it's like
you know when you go to school or
college or whatever
yeah and you get a review every week
yeah I think that yeah it is a g6 is the
best example for me as I ever
I never absorb a move in the first try
yeah you got to give you got at each
enemy 12 different times
I learned 1/12 of it each time and then
12 funds later I know all move perfect
analogy if you if you Jacko's telling
echo yeah hey don't complain like don't
complain problem-solve don't who cares
about how you feel
care about the objective kind of thing
you told me that one time even two times
I'd be like cool that's some dope man I
need to do that and then next week next
month six months later do you think
that's sticking with me maybe resonated
with me maybe not but no I don't wanna
yeah if you're saying it every week to
the point where it's like I don't even
hear your words I just know it as the
concept is just in there it's that's one
like when I hear people complaining
that's a big red flag violations just
sticks out like a sore thumb if I see
someone blaming someone that's the
reason it sticks out because he's so
back through this idea of having
different seasons if it was season one
people would did the recommendation was
to go back and listen to them all again
so you'd get reiterated on these
asteroids yeah good in theory but it
doesn't work that way I think I don't
know that's a thing I don't know 100 and
then we do that season one season one is
two straight years of podcasts yeah yeah
that could work cuz you know how cuz
this is the concept imagine you take one
week off the restart season - oh I don't
know anyway I said I like the way you've
been doing it to be honest it's my input
one guy it's my input well you do have
50% of the vote here apparently oh all
right well let's get these questions
yeah like I said in your court questions
yeah these are like yeah yeah I like
them though okay first question
oh I'm gonna read these just how they're
listed and then we'll go through you
know they're swimming and or running for
BJJ conditioning session mark yes
swimming and running are good for
conditioning I would recommend that you
use Sprint's slash interval training for
both and I think that's gonna get you
where you want to be also it's good to
have that good base cardio yeah yeah so
that's good too
but yeah they're both good the best
conditioning for jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu
that's the the shortfall of that is that
you can sometimes push you've never mind
sometimes you can push yourself harder
in with burpees or with some kind of met
Conor or swimming or running you know
you go do sprints you should be
breathing you'd be able to make yourself
breathe harder doing Sprint's than you
can doing the rounds of jiu-jitsu for
conditioning yeah now the rounds of
conditioning in jiu-jitsu are more
important but if you want to push
yourself extra hard you got to do
something else yes women running for
jiu-jitsu conditioning yes they're good
yes you sprints
yeah I agree obviously as far as you
just I just learned this and I watch it
was on a marcelo garcia video randomly i
don't know where he was like okay i
don't do any other external exercises
for conditioning whatever dude I used
uses conditioning but I don't just do
regular jujitsu this I do and he
demonstrated it and he was going against
a he's obviously a high the highest
loves black belt so he grabs a guy yeah
and the guys a blue belt I think and
he's like okay this is how you do it for
conditioning is let go we're gonna fight
we're gonna go for whatever a minute
however many minutes they go and he's
like buh buh buh he's got one move next
to move he's just going on all he's not
even finishing moves you go to the next
one then he'll finish then they start
again and he's going to tell he's going
hard he's essentially going as hard as
he would if he had only 30 seconds where
five seconds left on a high level
competition that's how hard and fast
he's going and um he was like okay and
he explains you just you're just your
focus is going from move to move as fast
and as hard as you can and you're
breathing at all this stuff because
that's how you get conditioning with
jiu-jitsu and I was like dang man that's
that's good because think about it just
like how you said when you know you have
six rounds to go into regular jujitsu
training so it's so easy you're just
focusing on doing your jujitsu and with
jujitsu is energy conservation like all
these things that are anti conditioning
reasons they are so you can you know get
into good spot to use it let me show you
that one one step even more granularly
if you take six rounds
the last 30 seconds of each round it's
and I talked to Taylor and Andy about
this and I said hey guys when we get to
the last 30 seconds there should be no
cruising allowed at all you should be
going for the finish and you should be
going for the finish like if you got 30
seconds left go for the finish if you
got 30 seconds left in you're in a bad
position go for the escape as hard as
you can burn yourself out yeah that's a
huge difference between how you can just
go into I'm guilty as charged because
like you said part of jiu-jitsu is
energy conservation and so for me I'm
really good at conserving energy yeah
you can be cross eyed mounted on me and
you're you're not gonna make and I know
I know
no I'll be arrogant right now if you
mounted me or you got across the side on
me and we had one minute left you cannot
submit me yes you know what I mean like
you cannot submit me I'm really good
I've had Dean Lister
you know mounted an on side control for
the last 22 years yeah right so I can
defend myself well so if you have one
minute now if I gave you five minutes
that that story might people we have one
minute that's how much time is left yeah
I can completely go into cruise mode and
that's the wrong answer if you're going
to try and get and if you're if you're
trying to survive for some reason okay
well then yeah utilize the v
conservation skills but if you're trying
to get some conditioning work and
prepare yourself for aggressive
tournament-style situations you best put
out yeah and that's why I would kind of
in a way going back to what you said
about having a coach is where the coach
will be like hey shark tank you know
something like oh yeah they kind of
avoid your capability yeah they avoid
your capability to treat you Jitsu as
just regular jiu-jitsu and the energy
conservation efficiency all this stuff
you know that that's when a lot of
people ask me what should I do for my
first tournament is in three days what
should I do watch what should I look out
for and what I tell people is that okay
the person that you go against in the
jiu-jitsu tournament is going to go
harder against you than anyone has gone
against you in the gym period in the
story it is a whole nother level of
competition that you know white belt
versus white belt the first time you go
on a tournament as a white belt the
person you're going against is going
harder than anyone has gone against you
in the gym period yeah
you can't even when we would have MMA
fighters fighting in the UFC it's near
impossible to get get to get the
training partners to go as hard against
that guy as as their opponent is going
to go yeah it just it's just not there
there's no legitimate fire now
occasionally you know you get guys that
are really good training partners and
they'll push you but that's why we do
Shark Tank yeah because it's hard for me
to get you know four guys lined up to
roll with you and everybody's gonna go
as hard as I possibly can yeah
everyone's going to match what you match
a little bit they're going to use what
they have to use and that's so two men
and those guys watch out for there's a
bunch of those elements in there when
when you're in a training scenario
because you don't have this you don't
have that background hum of this means
everything like a competition you know
so yeah I mean then actually know who
does go super hard is people that have
never trained you to do before forget
I'm in the gym the competition but it
really feels like a competition to them
is so true so true I mean I've been on
the weird how crazy it is that you just
take a guy that completely believes that
they can kick everyone's ass if you
bring them the jujitsu gym and they just
get destroyed yeah isn't that crazy if
you're easy to just use a crazy thing
yeah it's an ego checker that's kind of
what I was thinking and then same thing
with kind of MMA I think jiu-jitsu and
MMA you know kind of the same deal where
it's kind of real you know um where you
know you're talking about you know
veterans come home and they come to
everyday life and you people have no
idea really what extreme stuff is you
know needs to be part you know they're
walking around just not knowing
meanwhile was a bit what they've been
through is is just so extreme they come
back and they know they have that basis
for comparison and you know you get this
teacher who's like you know mouthing off
to the guy I remember he goes didn't it
didn't wor teach you anything
oh yeah kind of thanks and they don't
know they don't know nothing you know
give them one day give that teacher one
day with you know it's just a big
eye-opener
so that's kind of how I feel with like
jiu-jitsu and MMA and stuff and when you
go out and when you hear people talking
you know I just don't
I keep that guy's ass you know kind of
thing like oh my gosh yeah I'll give you
go to the gym one day walk do two rounds
under normal there three rounds because
one round people think you got lucky I
know that's the ground and I go well
that might have been locked but and
after you submit someone three times
they're like okay that there's something
I don't understand here and I want to
learn it give them one ten minute round
oh god watch him just be like this guy
can't do this I can't like it to the but
especially early on you get a ten minute
round and you know because when you're
going against someone there's that
you're locked into it yeah I'm not a
straight-a normal a normal person isn't
going to be destroyed after because
they're going to be in a competition
white belt mode going as hard as they
can against someone that's not using any
strength or energy at all he's
destroying them and submitting them and
every 30 seconds manage other - all
right well yeah the runner what I did
like about running like you know three
four miles um it what I found that that
provided was um you know when one will
do take takedown battles and no one's
getting each other I felt that it really
kept me going like just being on your
feet doing it like low-intensity pushing
and then I really felt that that it
helped that yeah agree check next
question X slash what advice can you
give on push-ups and benchpress for
shoulder and PEC injuries slash recovery
okay real quick for all for all injuries
what I say is do what you can and do
what you can without hurting yourself so
for instance if you can't do a full
push-up because it hurts your shoulder
guess what the whole do a quarter push
up and do a bunch of them and just get
that range of motion you're not going to
get a full workout but to get that range
of motion get it working and then maybe
in a week you can do a half push-up and
then you do have push-ups and then and
of another three weeks you can do a
three quarter pushup and then eventually
you can do a full push-up and then you
start doing your deep push-ups in
between rings or whatever you
you get it back that's what I do I do
that with every body part that I have
that might be injured for whatever
reason I do what I can you know I do
what I can
and specifically I'll tell you what
benchpress I would use dumbbells and not
barbell because a barbell locks your arm
into position and this is very similar
to an Americana or a Chimaera both of
those submission moves in jujitsu are
based on the same kind of general range
of motion as a benchpress there there's
definitely something different about it
and obviously it's you can do bench
press I mean people bench press you know
hundreds and hundreds of pounds on a
barbell so it can be done but
essentially it is is a similar motion if
your aren't like with an Americana which
is a submission hold in jujitsu if you
can move where your wrist is you can it
doesn't hurt at all you know if you put
your wrist up by your head it doesn't
hurt all they can personally do an
Americano you all day once you bring it
down now it submits you and that's the
way I look at a barbell that's why I
haven't done barbell bench press and I
don't even know how long especially like
a going for max I haven't done that I
don't even remember the last time I did
it but yeah for any of these injuries
that you might have do what you can use
minimum you use the use the range of
motion as you can don't reinjure
yourself you know don't be don't be
stupid
but if it hurts your knee when you get
to a half a squat do a quarter squat or
little you know do a 3/8 squat yeah
so that's what I recommend to get
through those yeah then it's um that's
kind of the thing and I know this from
an I had knee surgery and I had a quick
recovery quick recovery and the reason
that was was because a you're gonna be
smart just like are saying getting smart
about you don't I had knee surgery I'm
not going to go Mac squat you know there
for later there's no kind of thing so
yeah you take it slow but at the same
time you go you treat it like a workout
do serious like research about it yeah
yeah exactly right so P some people was
I forget when I said I don't know if I
said on here but um
people would get a shoulder injury for
example and part of the rehab is like
the stabilization right or your core and
then they'll be like ah I'm gonna skip
that day because I don't feel anything
that's AB muscles why would I do that I
have a shoulder injury so I'm going to
skip that and you know the next day I'll
do my little shoulder exercises I'll go
through the motions and that's it but if
you treat it like a frill workout like
where you stretch it you kind of push
yourself not in weight but you know you
do if you do a more range of motion all
that stuff every element of your rehab
has to be real important to you
including the consistency yeah and if
you do it that way that'll be how don't
to me and I don't know I don't know the
the history of the this question or
nothing but um bench press for shoulder
injuries and recovery not that they
they're no yeah they don't that's not a
hand-in-hand thing like so if you if
you're concerned about whether you know
whether or not to get your bench backed
up after you have a shoulder injury okay
but they still the bench has nothing do
with recovery from the sort shoulder
injury what you do is all the little
stable stabilization muscles in there
like these weird motions and stuff like
that a lot of times that's where you
know another good another good
compliment this is why I had a shoulder
injury and it it hurt really bad to do
regular push-ups but I could do Wayne
push-ups because it allows you to move
away from those range merchants that
hurt you so that's good but yeah bench
press for shoulders not good I had a guy
a new guy officer in Ramadi who had
showed up during deployment and he had a
bad shoulder for something he's like hey
surround I was wondering if you give me
any good you know exercises I could do
for for my shoulder which I have you
know a bad shoulder and I was like dad
do muscle ups and he kind of looked at
me a little strange and then later
realized that yeah you know I was having
fun and yeah that's a joke he's lucky I
didn't like heed my advice at the time
yeah he just thought wow this guy's
you say so okay and rotators any rotate
like this you know like throwing ball
motion just controlled in that that's
gonna get you back
sorry can recover you can work on yeah
and that's the thing and again you have
just treat those rehab because there's
nothing glamorous about this that
throwing motion actually like a rotator
cuff exercises or there's nothing happen
exactly right yes you will be like oh
yeah I'm not doing that no when I was
I'm benching as you know doing some
military press you'll yeah but if you do
press charge like demonstrating so I had
a kind of a shoulder like from the day
before and sergeant's like hey you know
Sarge demonstrate they're kind of heavy
handedly and he rips my shoulder and it
I felt that pop up man so now I can't
lift anything above my head so I all I
did was that rotator cuff like a program
it's like this way front back and then
down here this one mmm did that and it
was only for two weeks
and it was just back yeah unfortunately
sergeant moved to Connecticut is he's
one of my favorite training partners
yeah you yeah he gives you an accurate
yeah after yeah and when he gets uh when
he's like his go-to cuz he wrestled he's
got a sick double he would just get in
this double leg mode he'd get up or
something like we'd be scrambling he'd
get up and I'd see the look on his face
here come here it goes that he blasts
that double that's so hard launch me I
remember one time I rolled with him and
I think you may have like seen part of
it of something and you're like oh how
was it rolling massage okay you know how
you kind of explain how the role went or
whatever and I was like a man and then
he he got he turned on this Modi you're
like oh yeah he Sarge doubt on your
funniest every was did you see him do
that a slingshot so he used to have this
defense from from getting triangle and
he would just I I can't really explain
it but he would basically launch should
be other human being okay
across the mat and it was awesome every
eye sees I'm gonna lock up and he didn't
care like medical they put a triangle on
him and he just he'd go into you do the
slingshot you just laugh at it because
he know he's getting ready to launch
somebody
so just ours down got a school in
Connecticut by the way here in
Connecticut you can go train there what
is it what's this all I didn't know that
it's called jujitsu life oh that's what
it's called yeah there you go yeah do
one of my old teammates and on my
longtime training partners to get some
with next next question do you prep your
own food daily or eat on the hoof and
grab what you can I do both if I if you
know I generally don't pack up something
and make a little meal so my travels all
weird and random but yeah so what I can
and and I'm at home so I make something
up yeah yeah but I eat out a decent
amount I got my goat cheese and I go eat
there sometimes they make good food for
me yeah if you're on the program like
back in the dreams yeah when I was in
decisions I'd bring lunch for sure but
it was never lunch because I never ate
lunch I never ate lunch never remembers
like okay guys I'm gonna go get me leave
me alone for the next hour cuz I'm gonna
go eat lunch no never ate lunch never
you've never seen you saying hey guys
okay let's call it for now and we'll go
eat lunch then I'll meet you back here
in an hour
no not how you know don't eat long but
what do you do work through lunch and
stay late and then so when to eat then
just eat your anytime at all yeah and be
on the phone I can eat and be at the
computer I can eat and you know unless
we're doing something physical and even
then eat while you're doing something
physical as long as you're not doing on
ComNet yawn Carolee but you missed this
one what would you recommend for
striking training is an effective real
application practice boxing Muay Thai
mocha that's real easy start with boxing
because it's easier to learn you don't
fulfill big kicks but is very effective
martial art boxing and then once you get
decent at that you now you can go into
more time then learn how to use your
legs your elbows your knees your head so
there yeah agree the boxing - and this
is strange but it's absolutely true is
if you if you don't have experience
throwing punches and landing punch
it's it's surprisingly hard you have to
ever punch someone's face and landed it
effectively yeah yeah you know like um
like on the movies you know you see a
force MacGyver a lot very used to punch
people and then he always shake his hand
like oh yeah like I hurt man
every that was kind of one of the fun I
was really about your punch that's the
thing actually a lot it was funny I'm
sure I'm a guy were there trying to make
like oh my god were such a softy in that
way I was hurt I work he's hardcore like
his brain like Marge Marge oh you know
he doesn't carry a gun you know he's not
that guy one has a paperclip it has a
brain eggs-actly right paperclip harvest
I mean I've nonetheless that's kind of
what I was indicating but I thought it
taught kind of a good lesson where if
you you know you watch on TV guys just
punching guys in the face in the head
but you can especially if you don't have
a very fun gene you can probably will
break your hands
yeah or hurt your hand earlier sure so
if you if you go train boxing even just
once a week a little bit some boxing or
whatever you really get to learn like
okay if I start throwing these punches
the difference all crazy it's just like
jujitsu like six months of jiu-jitsu
destroys someone with no jiu-jitsu last
month the boxing does pretty damn good
against someone with no boxing for sure
yeah yeah the only thing with boxing and
like striking you can kinda not really
MEP we're gonna get mat it even saying
this but I'll mean this like straight up
literally but in the street you can have
kind of some training you know like if
you get in a bunch of street fight oh
yeah yeah yeah
you young people face Euler yeah exactly
right you learn what you learn actually
mostly from being a legit street fighter
did you learn the mindset
yeah no stupid that sounds but here's
what you learned if I punch this guy as
fast as I can before he's expecting it
I'm a sucker punch him you'll become a
good street fighter that just that's
what Street Landing is street planning a
lot is done on aggression you know and
if you get in my face my punch you in
the face you know if you look at me and
say what's your pop boom and I hit you
yeah that that's what a really like a
good experienced street fighter that
kicks a lot of people's asses that's
what they do
they are over aggressive they don't care
about getting in fight they're not
thinking about their fighting and so
when you say hey what's your pack right
guy says hey what do you look crack
that's a that's what a that's what a
street fighter it is they're going to
take action very quickly yeah that's so
you can learn a lot from that so when
you take that in someone you know when
someone shows up at the MMA gym and this
is we you know I got a lot of street
fights yeah and if there that's most the
time that's [__] but if it's not and
they're actually a guy that's been in a
lot of fights and it's only so helpful
because now they got someone that
they're going to shake hands with and
then engage in combat so they've lost
the what in am i saying it's a not a
real thing you know some of my friends
growing up were really good street
fighters and this is how I'm saying
that's with kind of a little bit of
knowledge is my friends that were really
good street fighters what was made them
good street fighters wasn't that they
studied boxing wasn't that they studied
you did too it was because they had a
very aggressive mindset and so someone
would say hey what's your crack and they
were going ballistic right you know or
someone's someone says who do you look
at crack and that's it and it wasn't
actually wasn't crack it was crack crack
crack crack crack crack crack crack
crack crack crack crack run away or or
you know that's so yes that's what a
street fighter has they have a mindset
of they have been in fights before but
they know that the aggression will take
him a long way yeah it's kind of like a
guy in the state basketball who you know
he has a home court or something and he
just shoots a lot of shots you know yeah
like he knows he knows how to make those
shots but then now you put them on the
back here court you guys know technical
training with dribbling or anything yeah
yes that is true that is your you you
can learn the mechanics yeah and then
your own going your own organics but the
mechanics and then you could and
mechanics are going to be almost less
helpful
yes that's what I'm actually
understanding the mindset of what's
going to happen in a fight now the
mechanics will be more helpful in
basketball but it's not once you get in
a real game the first basketball game I
ever played
I knew the mechanics and I got destroyed
every pass I threw for the first 10
passes I figure got picked off and I
just went down the other end of the
court and scored
I'm not even kidding that happened at
kindig-it my dad was like the Hoosiers
kind of guy jeer see the movie Hoosiers
and exactly a year to work the mechanics
gonna work ball handling you're gonna
work passing you're not shooting no no
sparring or what is it called
scrimmaging right you're going to learn
and then that would have been cool if I
would have had a coach that had a
different mindset but the coach had the
same who's your mindset as my dad which
is mechanics mechanics mechanics so I
worked on all these mechanics like
really good ball handing at good passing
and then I got it it was the first game
I played in basketball I had never
actually little maybe I'd done a couple
live games but I'd never played against
any one skilled dribble down the court
may I was a point guard dribble down the
court held up my fingers about okay
we're gonna run play number three went
over the side threw the ball and the
dude just picked it off and the kid that
I was playing against was a really good
player that other guy that was guarding
me just destroyed me and the reason was
didn't have the experience of live games
now I actually brought that mentality
when I was running training I always you
know you can sit there and learn
mechanics in the kill house you can sit
there and learn the mechanics of doing
immediate action drills out in the field
the mechanics are good you have to know
them but you have to also be live and
that's why I loved when they win the
SEAL Teams when we went from just having
live rounds and paper targets which
everyone was that was like the highest
form hey we tried we trained with live
fire that's the best thing and that's
what I was raised to believe as soon as
I saw we had this ammunition and then
once I realized how effective simulation
was like you don't even need simulation
even to run around literally saying bang
bang at each other but he's got people
moving and it's going to help you so
that that mindset came from trying to
not be just be Hoosiers you know
Hoosiers that the movie Hoosiers a
basketball movie it's an awesome movie
but the beginning is all just drilling
and my dad because I didn't play
basketball incidental improvised ball he
said okay so he's teaching me how to
play basketball but he was like a
Hoosier guy they're gonna be good
defense they're gonna be good at ball
handling and and then unfortunately
coach was the same way my first coach
was the same way seventh grader eighth
grade just like a Hoosier it would have
good defense and I drilled hook up well
I'll be careful with that but someone
that played street ball someone that
played street ball exactly yeah and and
and didn't no one ever taught him ball
handling no one ever taught him the
theory behind a zone defense
yeah that guy would have done infinitely
better than I did in my first basketball
game my dad must have been hanging his
head Shane we must have been what a
loser how did I raise this kid yeah well
yeah yeah sure the same same kind of
thing yeah those street fighters they
know how it feels to like land a punch
yeah they know they have this kind of
intuitive gauge on you know kind of
distance in a way you know just they've
been there yeah and that's why when you
train people for anything even in the
business world like don't just train the
people the mechanics of a conversation
that they're supposed to have if their
leader just don't train them on the
mechanics here's what you say read this
script no put them live fireman they're
wooden live fire role play with them
have them sit with you while you're
going through something have them go in
there and talk to somebody that you told
them how to act and act all crazy to do
that do that with them yeah check check
do you take creatine I do not take
creatine I have taken creatine I believe
it isn't it is an effective supplement
when remember phosphagen losses yeah
when that came out I was the first
creatine supplement I was drinking so
much that it was vanilla it was
disgusting and I was on the I was on a
ship at the time with a seal platoon and
we were all trying to get as big as
possible we were all taking creatine I
was drinking so much phosphor gain that
I had to hold my nose and do it you to
hold my names and do it like a shot made
me want to throw up
that's like a weight gainer yeah I was a
gym and then this phosphor game yeah the
gainer yeah whichever one I was on tops
for gain and yes only had an inflator
which I don't even like vanilla flavor
but that's it there's your mistake no I
was only alfred at the time when it
first came out we were all in the game
but yeah creatine is it is effective I
never really had any of the big side
effects where people say you get
dehydrated and whatever literally had
that bloated I never really saw much of
that but I don't take creatine right now
I haven't taken it for a long time
me neither and I don't actually I never
did maybe no I took this thing called
beta gin I think there is creatine in
that who's like long time ago yeah then
it's good I think maybe I don't know but
yeah I don't know much about it um as
far as what's true and what
it's not a you're great things and I
could jump things welcome to the
interwebs yeah next do you ever if you
ever surf in Europe
I have not served in Europe I would like
to surf in Europe I know that you boys
up and Ireland got some big slabs so
maybe at some point I'll get up and surf
what there looks awesome it's very
inconsistent though I'm very crazy with
the title differences so that's some
point to you would be cool your surf in
Hawaii I have I have yes you ever been
to Kauai before No
December think about it next question
check I have a bad back and I need to
lose a hundred pounds any advice on what
exercises to start with to kick-start
things you know you have a bad back you
need to take care of that and I have no
idea what that means that could mean so
many different things what you need to
do is you need to probably you know
start to figure out what you can do you
probably want to go to your doctor and
say hey what can I can not what can I do
and what can I not do and then doctors
sometimes are overly cautious
so maybe get a second opinion switching
to Aerith but the bottom line is if you
got a hundred pounds to lose here's what
you need to do start moving some way
somehow whether that starts off is
walking whether that starts off as doing
some calisthenics whether it starts off
is riding an exercise bike you need to
start moving that's what you need to do
and then you need to fix the diet
because that's where most that weight
loss is going to come from and that's
the best ways to kickstart things agree
yes and you know how ok the diet thing
real quick this you know how like
certain things you go into certain
situations and you're hit with feelings
or certain things that you weren't
expecting you're like I did rejects
really yeah but you know then you'll
fall into certain pitfalls because you
like dang I didn't really expect it to
be like this you know and maybe if you
went in there expecting certain things
or understanding and certain things are
going to come about you have more will
so the diet thing when you change
diet if your diet let's say your typical
diet is poor mean typically that's going
to mean it tastes good in some way Jack
you know what it'd be you know fast food
or right just whatever is do Fred yeah
less sugar yeah exactly right so it
tastes good and foods that taste good
have a certain chemical reaction in your
brain and they play um they go
hand-in-hand
pleasure we'll call it pleasure so when
you um when you refine your diet
typically that means it's going to be
less sugar
you know sometimes less that it depends
on what kind of diet you know you go on
but if it's if it's a better diet
compared to your junk food diet based on
taste and pleasure versus less tasty
exactly right so it's one thing to be
like okay it doesn't taste as good and I
can handle that that's cool but the
chemical reaction in your brain is
basically going to be telling you like
you need pleasure you are being deprived
the pleasure and you know they're
telling your brain is telling you it's
not just pleasure it's sustenance it's
your five moves on me yes not just you
want you need yeah that doughnut yeah
that was United now immediately I got to
get over that and people call it
cravings
that's your craving but it's one thing
to be like okay craving I can overcome
that for a lot of people but it's it's a
weird feeling it goes beyond just it you
want to know a good way to kick things
off go on a fast man go on the side yeah
24 hour fast because I'll tell you what
the best thing about going on a fast in
my opinion is how it recalibrates your
your it recalibrates
to things your actual feeling of hunger
and it recalibrates your taste buds to
yes because when you're eating this
beautiful stuff all the time it is long
left I so good and you just it just need
more of it yeah whereas once you go on a
fast when you have a glass of water it
tastes good just a still good when you
and then when you break the fast and you
have whatever you're going to have
whatever your first meal is it takes
really good and it's very satisfying
because you haven't eaten yet yeah your
needs aver your needs so that's one of
the best things I found about fasting is
it recalibrates those those two things
hunger and taste and things too
to taste better it's like have you ever
drink coca-cola right so you're used to
that sweet sweet sweet thing every once
in a while for me because I don't drink
it if I cased it it tastes all over the
comments and over the top and B that's
because I've fasted from having Coca
Cola's for so long that it just is a
taste that I don't even like anymore
yeah but there's a middle ground where
hey you can have it you go wow this
tastes incredibly good but I don't need
a ton of it because I got the
satisfaction of the case right so yeah
that's another good way to kick things
off yes go on a fast go on a 24-hour
fast you don't need food like I told my
when my daughter was going through the
last wrestling season she was telling me
she says you know dad I was I was
thinking okay she's fasting or not
fasting she's cutting lately never mind
fasting she got weight if water and her
thing was like you know if I were a
person can live for 30 days without food
I can make it till post weigh-ins yeah
you know yeah you're not starving
kiddingly as big tony btf tony used to
say like you're not gonna die oh you're
in a dialogue no so calm I thought for
Tony the other day on the phone it was
all fired up we were laughing really
hard today
I was telling a I was telling a story
and he was laughing so hysterically that
it was hard to understand it so yes Tony
yeah that was his thing well you're not
gonna you're not gonna just die you
don't have anything right now yeah stop
man that's all that says so much about
what when you feel like eating just
picture Tony yeah this picture btf tony
sitting there going you're not gonna die
if you don't have that so the calm yeah
just just be tougher yeah wrong with you
Manny that's such a good flow mean it's
real funny when he says it you know it
makes you feel like real real post but
he's kind of right you know it's like
you're like oh my gosh I'm just I've
been just crazy you know how
how embarrassing is that imagine this
imagine if you had to announce your
stupid pathetic crazy craving and needs
wants to the world yeah you know I
imagine if I had to walk into a room
into a group of people and say I cannot
live another second longer without a
doughnut like that would be so
embarrassing as a human to say that and
yet we think that way and we act that
way to say it right but our actions
basically act that way we know that the
doughnut is not needed yeah we know that
the doughnut is not needed
yeah if you were if you were starving
for for 38 days you de doughnut if you
run day 37
hold off you might buy the station yeah
yeah it's so bad man you said you meant
and made me think that it's so bad that
this is an official effective way to
like improve your diet this right here
don't keep junk food in your house yeah
like that's what your junk food junk
food in your house you can't control
yourself yeah and you're a rationalize
to you well you know what it's no big
deal I'm not gonna start that coming too
fast in three weeks anyway so I'm glad
eat this whatever right now that's how
bad we're we can't control herself I
like that idea just thought of just
having to announce your week thoughts to
the whole world
yeah and how stupid they would say if
you're going to carry out an action
that's weak you should have to verbalize
it first yeah I am about to eat this
donut because I cannot survive without
it
announce your rationalization to the
world yeah I'm going to skip this
workout because my left pinky is sore
from jujitsu three weeks ago well no
well that's just that's a better
rationalization than a lot of ones that
have dealt with straight up I don't feel
like it I straight up that's not very
come on Joe
next question PD te D or HGH question
mark what that means do you take these
or or which one is better
yeah well PD is the general term
performance in a head
drugs and she H is a human almost I I
think is that asking or this person is
asking if you take them why not or your
thoughts on them the only
performance-enhancing drug that I take
is jock away
I take jock whitey now it which being
run through the Olympic Committee to see
it looks like it's going to get banned
in the Olympics jock elected yeah yeah
really beginning record yeah tell me
you're coming new records are being
practiced
yeah no I don't think anything never
have yeah the HTH and NOPD's perform
what's the performance performance
enhancing drugs steroids bro yeah but so
let's say technically is caffeine a
performance yeah III think it actually I
don't know I don't know if I don't know
well it is no I do know that it is in a
performance-enhancing drug it is yeah
people technically and when they
scientifically measure it is a
performance tantrum drug but I think for
some reason it's legal
yes like even in the Olympics or
whatever I don't think you I think you
do have a maximum that you could take I
don't think I could just book fill your
blood with caffeine and and go do you
know your wrestling match but but Mikey
yeah kind of off yeah interesting
yeah my am have this friend called ke ke
kula kill coin is his name in college
he's like I wanna say outside linebacker
maybe inside no no he's a linebacker so
and so he'd have a real good workout
and you know when you work out what
lifting you'd have you'd have a pump
right you know you walk around so you
pick off his shirt sometimes anything
like like guys guys I think I'm on
steroids always thought that was the
funniest thing
nonetheless oh yeah no no steroids rted
jump go next can you believe in aliens
I'm assuming they mean extraterrestrial
and yes I do mean that I my opinion on
aliens is that I'm sure in this vast
unknown world and universe there is
likely to be other life forms that have
some level of intelligence
interesting how sure on the scale from
one to ten how sure you are obviously
you can't beat a not very um over a five
but well actually when you take the
entire universe yeah which is so massive
we can barely even comprehend it the
chances are decent that there's some
other some how intelligent lifeform out
there yeah and you almost become you
kind of have to ask wait like at this
very time but then when you think about
it there's really no time in a way like
that's kind of relative to so in the
whole existence would you say what nine
are you level nine sure is the nicest
matter of opinion don't know I think
nine I think like nine point oh so
you're a believer yeah I'm a believer I
would be vast like if some wizard guy
was like okay you get to make a bet do
you think there is or isn't I know the
answer do you think there is or isn't
you know we need a wizard be proof of
concept right there stop in your area
what if you the guy from the future oh
can somehow figured it out I don't know
right they they map the whole universe I
don't know whatever I would bet ya know
the cost is your life too by the way
like you have to make a bed you have to
make a choice and you if you get it
right you live get it wrong you die I
would I would bet yeah oh hell yeah very
I would bet yes I would right yes yeah
that's the thing is is you would also
it'd be interesting to have a scientist
or talk to a scientist about the
probability of human life like how
incredibly maybe guided at any minute
you like all the little things that had
to happen for us to end up here yeah and
it's whatever hand up again
oh yeah happening a lot but then again
you you you compare that to the unknown
one of this universe that is so large
it's in comprehensible it chances are
it's happened somewhere yeah else and
even just and that's in a way a
different point where it's like you know
what would it take to to make humans and
wind up being humans if you look at it
backwards
it seems really like oh my god
this is crazy like you know almost
impossible Auto percenter yeah miracle
kind of thing but you I can you can say
that with everyday thing if you look at
it backwards so like let's say I had a
um like Legos right okay we had this big
bucket of Legos it was more than one of
those big plastic tubs
there's just full of years and years and
years of LEGO sets and there's all in
there if I were to take that tub full
Legos and [__] pour it out on the
ground on a marble surface so they
scatter everywhere and and then it'll
you know when they all settle it'll be a
little pattern right Legos various
colors shapes sizes all kinds different
places spaces okay and to take that
exact pattern down to the nanometer that
exact pattern and be like this is the
most special pattern in the entire world
ever in the existence this one is there
is no way anyone ever ever ever could
recreate this exact pattern down to the
nanometer it's impossible that's why
this pattern is so special but it's just
one of many potential eventualities
really infinite you know and when you
end up at something and then say okay
that what we have to end up as is
special it that's looking at it
backwards like I said so it's like the
lottery winner you know the guy who wins
the lottery he's like oh my gosh I'm so
special I want to let no Christian if I
took a ping pong ball and I saw and I
had a mosh pit of 1 million people one
ping pong ball I throw it in the mosh
pit and then somebody catches it oh my
gosh I'm so special Beth someone's gonna
get it
someone's gonna get the ping pong ball
that's affirmative
yeah but it doesn't make it necessarily
special unless you look at it backwards
you know if that guy's like I'm gonna go
into another the guy doing the other
alien life-form could be something that
we could barely even imagine of what
it's yeah and not that that probability
was is what it is yeah or it's going to
be something like so small yeah and but
it if it's like more superior
intelligence it's going to be something
we don't recognize the same way like if
you have
of caterpillar on a leaf and I see it
from ten yards away I see that little
caterpillar right right there hey
caterpillar yelling at it you know the
vibrations from my voice are hitting it
and get a relic out the caterpillar has
no idea that you even exist don't even
though a human is doesn't know by your
problems doesn't know about your podcast
you know meanwhile you know a lot about
your podcast you know no he doesn't
listen to the podcast I can say with a
fair amount of I don't know maybe he
doesn't know he has big butterflies
plans future Jocko next question ex
question how can I incur from you can
talk more but no Liam help I had a war
about aliens or Legos I'm telling you
Lego patterns if you want people see
UFOs they go straight dude that's an
alien even though it's I unidentified
can't do that remember I was telling you
with that kids book ideas yeah you tell
me about that you know tell me again it
goes deeper knowing it I mean actually
smore about these flaws about people
consider or regard aleene's potentially
me Jocko
how can I encourage a sense of urgency
this is a hard one and in others yeah
well yeah I think I'm assuming that this
means with others but for either
yourself or others what you have to
realize is that time is going by very
fast and when you have projects that are
due the minute you look at them you got
to say this is going to take longer than
we think it's going to take let's start
moving on it now and then set yourself a
really tight timelines to make things
happen and that what that'll do is will
make you realize how far behind the
power curve you are that was one of my
rules when I was in the SEAL Teams was I
was always saying let's be as far ahead
in the power curve as power as possible
as we possibly can so is that a normal
expression power curve like that's the
thing that you're trying to stay ahead
of because it's going to smash you so I
would always you know just we didn't
slow down the power curve if we got we
thought we were ahead go ahead further
but I I always had a really good sense
that that power curve was coming to
crush us huh so that's what you have to
do get as far ahead of it as you can
tell everyone where it is we've set some
small goals say oh you don't think this
projects going to take long okay cool
let's just
finish this first six percent which
means this business and let's have that
done by tomorrow afternoon tomorrow
afternoon comes in there I mean close
okay guess what we need to align we need
to get a sense of urgency going so we
can get this done that's it I know that
to encourage a sense of urgency in
yourself what you can do kind of work
sometimes is you think about the feeling
you're going to have after it's done and
then consider things that you already
did get done you're have those little
you're different but sometimes we the
people have things that man we need to
do and it's just a small thing you know
and like I'll do it I'll do it later I'm
doing something right now do it I know
tomorrow yeah sure that's pretty
intuitive to you but you know sometimes
you just be like doing it later we're
just going to do it later because I'm
thinking about something right now or
I'm doing something right now and then
do it now or while you're thinking about
doing it just to do it I know yes I want
that you're under your kids all the time
hey do the dishes blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah you know to be done
I know that's the thing that's the whole
point right there
so when you do it when you do the thing
let's say you got it whatever you get a
respond to an email I don't know and
after you do it that just that feeling
right when it's done like saying that
that a that what didn't take much a
that's not gonna be case every time but
didn't take much and Beast
I'm done mmm my daddy said this saying
is what he'd say do it and it'll be done
a good sign and as a kid I was like
poker it's more that's like it is what
it is yeah I know it is what it is you
said that you don't have to say that you
know but what's your dad's first name
technically it's William Charles Jr okay
what we look like BC we have a new quote
from BC a CEO for Bill Charles filters
yeah yeah so BC is in the house you know
do it and it is done I like that one do
it and then it'll be done do it and it
will be done yeah I changes a little bit
doing it's done yeah same thing same
idea but his thing with always yeah
exactly same thing earth the exact words
BC to it and it'll be done yeah at me as
a grown adult
arguably yeah parallel words in impact
the way I wanted them now I'm seeing the
genius of it you know doing it'll be
done like you don't have to so here next
question if digital is not locally
available what would be the next next
best martial arts choice or the next
best thing or is the one way 70 mile
drive worth it thank you meaning it's
not locally available it's 74 why that's
a long haul
so yeah there's a lot of other available
martial arts I would say you got judo
and wrestling and those exist in a lot
of places that jiu-jitsu doesn't exist
so wrestling judo [__] those are all
good options great options you can find
a catch wrestling school there's so
there's definitely some options find a
good grappling but a real grappling
school what you want to watch out for is
a place that says it has karate kung-fu
and jiu-jitsu you want to watch out for
that place because that means the guy
just put that up there because you're
just getting popular yes so watch out
for that guy and that one's pretty like
across the board right there I mean I
can't really imagine many exceptions
where it's like correct you know like
all the other ones and jiu-jitsu and
it's the legitimate Judy it doesn't
happen very often now you might have a
place it says boxing wrestling or in
jiu-jitsu yes it's probably legit
because you've got legit boxing legit
wrestling legit judo and legit jiu-jitsu
so okay cool that's probably true but
when it's non legit things and they
throw jiu-jitsu on the end of it watch
out and whenever I'm talking about
jiu-jitsu I'm talking about Brazilian
jiu-jitsu I just got to make that clear
talking about Brazilian jiu-jitsu not
other forms of jiu-jitsu so be careful
of that know what they like in the
spirit of fairness there there very well
could be like you know because a lot of
these guys though they'll have this vast
background in like Kempo karate
you're not injure come on they're right
and then they you know usually guide you
to know for sure meanwhile they're
traditionalist but they're jujitsu
colleges legit that's why I said just be
careful oh yeah yeah be careful when I
bet it and most people if fifteen years
ago they started taking Brazilian
jiu-jitsu
they got their black belt there there
Tai Chi Quan whatever whatever martial
art is not at the on the list of what
they teach at their school it's gone
actually if they're a black belt in
jujitsu they're teaching Brazilian
jiu-jitsu and they don't say Brazilian
jiu-jitsu plus Bo Khan Quan or whatever
they don't say that they're going to do
that yeah and if they do do it I
actually am gonna question there are
some questions yeah there's questions
again can it be can there be a legit
person yes there kid there are some
legit dudes that are you know black
belts and Brazilian jiu-jitsu and
they're a black belt and some other
traditional martial arts that they took
before that that is that does happen
most of the time when they realize that
the white belt or blue belt in Brazilian
jiu-jitsu destroyed them and their
martial art they tell you for ten years
they don't put that on the list anymore
right that's why I that's what it does
to most people so that's why there's
questions yeah question there's
questions so yeah it's wrestling
wrestling what I know I'm missing I
apologize got folks out there from
missing but wrestling judo [__] catch
wrestling those net now if there's no
kind of grappling venue boxing Muay Thai
that's your next best option so that
you're still learning how to fight you
just aren't getting the groundwork and
you definitely want to get the
groundwork at some point so and then the
question on the 70-mile Drive I get this
a lot to some people they have no
martial art in their area and they have
a martial they have jiu-jitsu 70 miles
away what should I do
my vote in that situation is get some
mats at your house get two or three of
your friends that want to learn how to
fight start watching YouTube videos and
once a week on the Saturday go down but
that's jiu-jitsu school when we were
training it back at Fabio's brokenness
games there was there was people like
that they lived in they lived somewhere
and in the desert of Southern California
there was no jiu-jitsu they work 9:00 to
5:00 and then on Saturday they come out
and train and that's what they got and
they
go home and work on their drills with
their three guys that they were driving
80 miles to come and train on the
weekend so yeah that's that's a method
of doing it to you you can train on your
own with your buddies on the mats that
you get and watching YouTube and or
whatever online mechanism you want to
use and then once a week you come and
you make the trek and you learn and you
get to train with other people and you
see where you're at
yeah thank that's good yeah very good
yeah the it's next best thing is the
heart I guess it's some total matter of
opinion
but I feel like wrestling like if you
went um like well wrestling is like a
really good tool it depends on what
you're doing like why you're not doing
it yeah like for a self yeah wrestling
is awesome yes I know that that to the
heckling is an awesome wrestling is
gives you such a massive advantage not
only in jiu-jitsu but in life yeah they
give you an advantage so wrestling is
awesome that being said judo is awesome
too and if you train but there's a more
of the variation in judo schools right
and a high end judo school those people
are awesome and that's a great martial
art and you learn groundwork you learn
takedowns it's a great martial art don't
no question about it
there are some weak judo schools though
judo has a little bit of a tendency to
sometimes judo people can adapt some of
the traditional Mart's traditional
martial arts attitude including the
attitude of we're not actually training
and so that has happened but now that
that's less that doesn't happen very
often so yeah you can find a good you
well the way you find if it's good judo
school go and put on a game and say
let's fight or let me train with you
yeah and they're going to put you just
they're going to they're gonna take you
down and be able to work you over that's
what you do is do you know is very
similar to jiu-jitsu very similar in
jiu-jitsu so judo is a great thing to
have wrestling is a great thing to have
for sure
Samba is awesome Zombo is actually like
judo and wrestling take
hether so Sabo is great same would catch
wrestling again there's cat wrestling is
a little less with catch wrestling
you're you're a little bit more apt to
find something that doesn't actually
know what they're doing and so you have
to be careful of that there's some
phenomenal catch wrestling schools
though for sure so I think we got time
for looking on more of these yes chuckle
how do I get the desire to have
discipline how do I get the desire to
have discipline there I keep getting
asked this type of question how do I get
discipline or how do I want discipline
or how do I maintain discipline and the
answer it's it's simple answer but
obviously it's not easy and there's all
kinds of little tricks and methods that
people talk about and you know they have
some merit you know maybe they do work
these these things you know do the
little things people say and wake up
early I say that and write things down
and take cold showers and tell everyone
what you're going to do so broadcast it
and make promises or or make bets with
with your friends of something that you
don't want to lose and those things
those ideas they're cool I'm sure
they're going to have some impact and if
they work for you that's that's awesome
but but the fact of the matter is that
the reason discipline is hard to
maintain is because it is hard to
maintain that's what makes discipline
hard it's hard and if you hear me claim
that discipline is easy for me then
straight up
that's just my ego talking
that's what that is because I'm
unfortunately just as human as everyone
else and it is work to maintain the
discipline that's what it is
work holding the line maintaining the
standard giving no slack none that's the
discipline that's the discipline and it
is hard and if there's one thing I would
say that does make it easier it's to
envision what it feels like when you're
done what it feels like after you worked
out or you've held the line on your food
intake or you've pushed through some
monotonous project that you have to do
in all those things when they're done
that they feel good and contrary to that
envision what you will feel like later
when you let the discipline slack you
know the feeling feeling weak and
defeated and you know that you're
falling behind so get to know those two
different types of feelings and ask
yourself which one you want to feel in
ten minutes or in a half an hour when
when the thing is done when the
discipline has blende implemented
remember what that feels like and then
remember that those minutes and those
hours they turn into weeks and months
and years and holding the line in those
critical minutes will put you in an
infinitely better place
physically and mentally if you maintain
the discipline so work through the
weakness fight through the temptation
hold the line hold the line
maintain the discipline it is not easy
but it is worth it because yes because
discipline equals freedom and I think
that's all I've got for tonight
so echo
speaking of discipline perhaps in a
disciplined manner you could explain to
us how we could support this podcast if
we wanted to yeah if you want it for
sure I feel like we should like we
always do in a disciplined way top blood
on it just by just one I mean concise by
the way oh okay we're over to remember
half hours or something like that
something like this sure okay that
doesn't control that doesn't you're not
even that doesn't play into your head
does it you're in the game you're here
to get your job done you care long it
takes correct yeah nonetheless last time
I mentioned that I ran out of krill oil
you even said you should go to the store
and buy some yeah did you know the good
thing is when I went home from our
session it did come in Oh a long way
thankfully the rangitane oh yeah elbow
yes nice two of them or just one one put
it away 54 pounds you need another one
yeah so I want I want the zombie one for
it whatever the ranking ones cool but
the zombie one was really cool so
they're out of them I think they're the
same weight 54 someone 254th they're out
of them so I was like yeah I'll just
one of these just you know as a one-off
and then when the zombie ones come in
check
I'll get the two zombie one so where is
this what is this store everything is
that on it calm but I'm explain what it
is just keeps people don't know or they
don't understand the importance I think
it's important nonetheless krill oil
came in this is what you do and I
mentioned this before this is what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna try to do I should
just do it and it'll be done
stay on it you know what that is right
stay on it oh the automatic yeah oh yeah
would even call it three automatic
automata [__] automated shipment yeah
you just pay every month and it
automatically comes yeah yeah I think
you might even get the feelin though I
don't know but that's what I'm doing a
staff called stay on it yeah you know
what man that's an a lot of people or
companies do that you know like the you
know I know when you do it on other
stuff yeah I Milan like to bring you
know things that you just use all okay
desktop you're gonna have that that's
that's a good deal I mean that's a good
thing to do with basically everything at
one time when I was drinking mark
another check anymore hardly um who was
it was Rudy he asked me to do something
a video or something
I don't know and he was like hey can I
pay you in vodka and
I gave a savage says that over food
anyway and he goes can I pay you in
vodka
I didn't tell me get out of here I was I
was consider I'll sick wait a second
it kind of is like currency when you
drink every day you know it's guy like
I'm gonna spend that money anyway so I'm
like hey you know what I could do I'm
just thinking about it lasted for like
five seconds maybe 10 maybe 20 but I
talked to myself hmm think of how much
money I would have charged them like
double it or triple it and get that much
worth of vodka boom I just saved 75 you
know 66 percent you know I'm saying
okay move on nonetheless the point still
stands if it's if you don't have to
think about it just come you are to run
into this thing like me where I'm out of
krill oil for one week back she was
little less Italy doesn't matter I won't
be out of it at all so yeah stay on it
that's the one krill oil stron Bone
didn't run out of that by the way and
that's good man that stuff is good it's
weird how I told you right how my
shoulder was jacked like the chair
didn't bar here now but to be a healthy
and I didn't stop lifting you know how
you get tendinitis you're like I gotta
stop lifting or lift lighter you know
like every but lighter is for suckers
strombone stay strong get rid of the
tendinitis and any bone issues I think
if I'm not mistaken I'm not sure I gotta
go back on the website I get addicted to
that website it's like interesting stuff
I think it can delay or stop the onset
of osteoporosis I don't want to make
that clam not making that thing I'm not
gonna direct what I'm just saying that's
what strontium does nonetheless good
kettle bells on their workout stuff
especially if you like like you know if
you go and bench
I don't bench but if you do a you know
just repetitious shoulder press I don't
know it can get boring but if you're
into like interesting type workouts you
know how like do you have a mace throw
like I do yeah and yet like yeah yeah on
a club
yeah got me yeah that's why you work out
so much and oh really more because
you're out looking forward to it it's
all interesting anyone if you're into
those interesting workouts and school
cuz you can like yourself a bunch of
workouts just for one kettlebell you
know so maces and of course I got the
you know traditional stuff jump rope
whatnot but um like they have these
metal things I don't know what they are
but it's like you know these are for
working out so it's like man you can't
even get bored working out anymore
really when you go on there anyway
websites interesting too anyway this
stuff the supplements are outstanding
they do have um yeah I must say it this
nut butter blend
also I got some MCT oil yeah you know an
MC t MC t stands for yes I do medium
chain triglycerides it's good for you
you know I cook with that one and I put
it in what did you make like a dessert
with it or something all kinds of sauce
with it with some t-shirts you'll be
whipping cream something anyway go on
there get 10% off if you want 10% off go
on it calm /g Akko it's good one support
yourself support you joints for your
help I don't think you should be in a
situation anymore anymore given the
times when to not support your health
there's really no room for not
supporting your health right now all
your needs are met you're not going out
in like you're not hunting for elephants
yeah unless do that on a duck on flash
choco also good way to support your
brain is to read these books Eugene
sledge another one from him China marine
also around the for and a rumor for and
we go I'm reading it upside down there
and we go on oh those are powerful books
on the website choco podcast calm
there's a page it's called books from
the episode top menu click on it boom
all the books from all the episodes with
the link directly to Amazon you get
those books through there that's good
way to support Amazon click-through or
if you're doing any other kind of shop
and just click through our website and
get whatever you're going to get
including but not limited to these books
duct tapes duct tapes maybe do multiple
roles such tapes but even if there's
multiple rules I think it's still duct
tape where these got different types of
duct tapes still no ok or paper clips
particular or whichever MacGyver stuff
that you're into getting riding getting
more nice I'm going to bring them if you
ever go on Amazon and be like hey this
is cool and then you how they show you
the little suggestions and then you buy
all the suggestions do you ever actually
buy all the suggestions now because I've
disappointed
I need uh so I went on there and I got a
flashlight you know how nice flashlight
technology I also nowadays spreadsheet
nowadays back in the day remember the
ones that yet had like a kids like a
suitcase flies you know
big legs but they're big so those are
dope as a kid like if you had that one
you're like the man yeah exactly right
so kind of reliving it so I'm like let
me get a flashlight then you look at all
the new flashlights out oh my gosh these
are so I'm like okay I'm gonna buy this
on a Maglite back lights are dope
because you can hit people with it you
know in the event of having to use it
for a weapon so I get one and then I
click on it and there's various options
on the length of it my so I get the
regular went camouflage from my daughter
she's four she likes flashlights like
all kids do I get two for me one for
Sara - that's a long one like ass it's
called like a six cell meaning it takes
six batteries so you can imagine how
long netting it's like a straight up
baton mm with a flashlight on it so I
got I wind up getting nine flashlights
I don't need nine classes this is an
indication of a total lack of discipline
well yeah go to Amazon yes I hope you
dig a click through though yeah yes I
did and I got a book too by the way so
yeah sure I lacked Amazon flashlight
shopping discipline but I got some cool
flashlights there's this technique here
I'll show you it you might even know
this but I learned this in bouncer is
security training and this was a
technique that you're this is illegal to
use you can't use it as a security oh
because it's offensive it's not
insecurities minimum force necessary to
affect a whatever to defuse the
situation whatever so this is what it is
let's say this was a flashlight and this
say this is the light part right like so
usually as a layperson you hold the
flashlight like this right and you like
in law enforcement and stuff like that
they hold it like this kind of up above
like that so this is how you hold it so
you show you you grip it right there by
the the head of it with light you shine
it in the guy's fake crush I'd be like
calm down calm down calm down they can't
really see you they're just blinded by
the light
and then like uh-oh and they hear your
voice and calm down coming and then you
can get and you flip it around and hit
them with it and you get those long
Maglites but if this six cell full
batteries boom they don't see it coming
they don't flinch
they don't blink they don't anything
it's just a complete you see light one
moment for a split second the light kind
of goes down then your flash then you
see yeah you wake up that's it
and matter video I saw a guy doing it to
somebody I was like dang the guy is it's
like you know those eerie you know like
when you see a person die whether it be
on video or whatever he gets like shot
and his body just goes limp he doesn't
know it's coming nothing is that it
looked like that you got hit with it so
square and so hard and you didn't even
flinchin it's a real effective thing
don't do it to people unless they're in
your house or something like that anyway
I digress
also good way to support is subscribing
to the practice iTunes Google Play
Google Play and stitcher all these
podcasts in providing platforms also
YouTube technically is a podcast
providing platform so subscribe to that
one here's the thing about YouTube if
you don't know already it gives you the
added benefit of being able to see the
video version chuckles face talking
about these things so subscribe to that
we'll add some other excerpts on there
some enhanced excerpts that when we're
calling them through the enhanced one
with music on there right some b-roll so
it's called Bureau anything that's not
the actual thing anyway and also what a
sounds gonna fly out there last time I
was gonna put something on YouTube yeah
some more videos more videos hello to
him yet so whatever it's just it's just
a theory at this point but nonetheless
subscribe and boom you can you know
support that way also
Jaakko as a store it's called chocolate
store what's the website said online
store
Jaakko store calm so what this has if
you don't know already is t-shirts
hoodies I think I'm gonna put some light
hoodies on there summertime you don't
like that I do no heavier nothing yes
heavy heavy hoodie or no shirt yes do er
tank tops not really huh you do yes my
wife threw a bunch of mine away about
five or seven years ago she didn't like
no no they were just all old and ratty
and she's thrown away randomly yeah
which was awesome don't go really except
longer me that's not cool
hey man it's one of those to take one of
the four things that I still bring up to
her no kita my god should be I can't
believe a hotter just a dad I'd be
comfortable I had a tank top I don't
have an extra shoe them away yeah
same rule a see ya know there were no
she doesn't like the way you look in
those tank tops it's offensive their
Sensibility that's not cool yeah man I'm
just saying you know stop pointing the
finger start playing enough dumb right
that's the expression right yeah yeah
yeah you gotta watch out for that
strangely lol for your tank tops barely
my own you know point there is someone
did say actually not many people saying
tank tops would be cool
I don't wear tank tops you do apparently
yeah oh that's obviously a sore subject
yeah let's make some tank tops also to
do my whole wardrobe we take bring them
back at the gate up ready or not here we
come
another like I'm pre rat eat yeah oh
dang yeah you know those thing put them
on the on the sander yeah nonetheless
shirts are cool if you think they're
cool talk about docstore calm go in
there check out the shirts this rash
guards on there I think I I'm saying
obviously just my opinion the rash
guards are cool that's like to me
actually there's a lot of good things on
there in my opinion but nonetheless
shirts on there they're cool um if you
want to support do it that way go to
website see if you like something get
something hats are coming soon whatever
that means
but they'll be here soon also
psychological warfare if you don't know
what that is I know you do but let's say
you didn't know what that was here I'm
going to tell you it is an album with
tracks Jocko tracks chocolate saying
what ok these are the pragmatic logical
reasons why you shouldn't slip on your
diet or your waking up early or this is
why you should not skip through the
workout this is why you shouldn't slack
on the workout like all these little
things that you'll the probability of
you slacking on certain things in life
or they'll actually really but in the
event of you slacking on something and
you need a spot verbal verbal in
Psychological get this check this out
search psychological warfare chuckle a
link on iTunes or Amazon music or
wherever they sell mp3's get that and
get a little spot get a little spot for
your points of weakness in your yeah
dirty I said it and that helps also you
can get jock a white tee on Amazon by
the way we talked about a little bit
today the person said that they drink a
cup of jackal white tea this morning
before I left for muster 0:02 and ended
up at mustard 0:01 not saying that I've
proven jakka white tea allows you to
travel through time and space but here
we are so again this is a verified
purchase review the person that actually
experienced this so we need to keep that
in mind jakka white tea you know in
amazon.com also way the warrior kid book
for kids and possibly adults I think
we're starting to see that okay here is
a review I wish I had read this book
before it gives you an excellent path to
a successful fulfilled life it is very
easy but don't be fooled it's incredibly
deep too I think it is great for a
ten-year-old or for an eight-year-old as
you are never too old or too young to
learn the basics of an honorable life
worth living fantastic 100 stars so
that's pretty cool
pick up the book it's about how to be
better how to overcome the obstacles
that we all face and it's told to the
voice of a 10 year old boy named Mark
and his uncle Uncle Jake who comes into
his life to help them overcome some of
these obstacles so there you go that's
where the warrior kid also discipline
equals freedom field manual editing is
complete at this time so many of these
questions I get asked all about all the
time are laid out in this book food
workouts martial arts and my my
operating system what's you that I've
talked about on the on this podcast is
in the book in a written form this book
is like the podcast that you can read
and absorb and refer back to so the book
is like the podcast but you're going to
see it's not a normal book it's not
normal my publishers says we've never
published anything like this I don't
think there's anything else published
like this ever so it's a little
different it's not a regular book just
like this isn't a regular podcast just
plain equals freedom field manual you
can pre-order it right now and of course
extreme ownership leadership book based
on what I learned during 20 years in the
SEAL Teams about leadership and
especially from the Battle of Ramadi and
how to take those lessons and apply them
to the battlefield to business and to
life wrote that with my brother lave
babban who was on the battlefield with
me and Ramadi also we have a leadership
and management consulting company me
Lafe babban JP Danelle Dave Burke
leadership and management alignment for
your team if you want that email info at
Esalen front comm and finally the muster
Austin Texas July 13th and 14th too late
sold out
down with that one not done with it
doesn't happen but you can't come
because it's sold out no more seats we
were able to bump it up a little bit I
think we got to like 320 or 330 okay but
that's a lot we were supposed to only
have 300 and then we rearranged some
seeds or whatever so we got it to 320 I
think but that's it we can't we cannot
put anyone else in there sold out so the
next shot is back in San Diego September
14th and 15th back at the Omni Hotel on
the bay in San Diego a lot of people
from the first muster in San Diego are
coming back and I think that will be
awesome to hear from people okay you
went you went to the first muster you or
you learned some things then you brought
them back to apply them real world you
hit some obstacles what are the
obstacles that you hit let's figure out
how to get around them
that's mustard 0:04 San Diego California
after that we're not going to go again
with a muster for a while you know at
least until sometime in 2018 probably
once again in the springtime but later
in the spring so be aware of that if you
don't come to September it's going to be
a while and until the muster if you do
want to communicate and hang out a
little bit you can find us getting at
well you're not really getting after the
internet but you can find us typing
letters into a keyboard on the interwebs
that's right on Twitter on Instagram and
in the facebook keepo haha echo is that
echo Charles and I am at Jocko willing
and thanks for listening and subscribing
and supporting and spreading the word
but more important thanks for grabbing
ahold of the challenges and the
struggles in your life and learning from
them and then climbing up those
challenges like a Jacob's Ladder and
using them to elevate yourself instead
of letting them drag you down and when
you get to the top look around
and give someone else a hand pull them
up tell them what you learned try to do
it an attack for wait try and teach them
and look around and see who can help you
and teach you and what you can learn
from other people
and teach people to overcome challenges
the same way that you did the same way
we all did by learning from our problems
and our challenges and our struggles and
after we learn from them we grabbed them
by the throat and get after it so until
next time this is echo and Jocko out